- What's up, vlog, in the
airport actually heading
to Sweden, and actually,
are we going to Copenhagen
to connect?
I think we're actually
going, this is very meta,
I'm going to Copenhagen,
to connect to Gothenburg,
then to Stockholm, and this is
the prelim to a Copenhagen
keynote I gave very recently,
second session, you can and you can't.
Second session, very
deep, after first session
I already gave, that you've
seen, as you can imagine,
was really challenge to
kind of spur up new stuff
for a second session,
which we did, I'm fired up,
I hope you enjoy it, check it.
(dramatic hip hop instrumental)
There's a couple things
I wanna talk about while
we're here, and wanna
make sure I'm hitting
more mature businesses around
management and structure
and managing people, startup
culture, the framework
of attention, which is
I think the one thing
that really runs through
this entire conference, is,
before you can tell anybody
how good your trampoline
business is or your art business
is, or your SAS product,
or you as a personal brand,
we all are trading attention,
and I'm obsessed with
this, it is why I believe
anybody who's been
successful is able to achieve
their goals, and there's
a lot going on there.
So, I think, the thing
that I wanna start with,
is that we've gotta really
wrap our head around
the framework that we're living within
as business people.
This device is the remote
control of our lives.
control of our lives,
and you are going to be in a scary place
with the amount of time you
actually are looking here
versus looking in the actual world.
You may judge that, you
may think that's bad,
or sad, or ruining the human race, it's
completely irrelevant what you
think, it's what's happening.
And so, I wanna make sure that
everybody starts backwards.
For you to get what you want
in your life and business,
you have to give the other
people the thing they want
so that you get what you
want, I call it 51 49.
Basically, every relationship
I have, every business
dealings I have, and the way
I frame up my entire being,
it's why I have popularity
or cult of personality,
it's because I think it's
smart to give more to
an audience than you ask for in return.
And so, when you're
building your product and
your service, and whatever you're up to,
you need to find the angle of leverage.
You're competing with
a lot of other people
that want people's attention.
When I started working
with Budweiser, the beer,
it was crazy to me, I
walked into a meeting,
and I said, you know,
okay, we're competing
with Miller or Carlsberg,
or, we're competing, right?
And they said, we're
competing for share of throat.
Budweiser globally worries
about how much water
you're drinking.
How much Coca Cola you're drinking.
I mean, it was just really
interesting, and it was kind
of how I think about attention.
You may be thinking
you're competing against
somebody else who has
a trampoline business.
You're not.
You're competing against
anybody who has anything else
to do that weekend, in
Denmark, with those four hours.
So we are living through
a world, my friends,
where there's more options than ever.
How many people here
manage, how many people here
have more than ten employees?
Raise your hands?
Right?
We're living in a world
where our employees
have more options than
ever, either to do things
for themselves, or other
employers, and no matter
how good your labor laws
are and how long they have
to stay with you before
they go to the new job,
they still have options
greater than there were
ten or 15 years ago.
So, I think the biggest thing
that I think a lot about
is supply and demand.
It is such a simple,
basic business trade, and
it's something I'm very
intuitive towards, and it is
basically how I think about
everything, how I manage
my people, how I create
my business, how I treat
my customers, it is a
supply and demand world,
and you need to understand that the cost
of creating things that can
pull our customers' attentions
away from us, has gotten
so low, that there is
so much supply.
There is so much supply of
information, and videos,
and pictures, that this is
the reason that I believe
that advertising, not that it's dead, but
the thought that you're
gonna put out something
that is selfishly in
your interest, and you're
gonna get somebody to
actually pay attention to it?
With the technology
advances that we have today?
And with all the supply of information?
Is almost impossible.
And every day that goes by, it
will become more impossible,
so, number one, first and
foremost, I need people
to start thinking that
they're a media company,
and a publisher, more
than they're an advertiser
for their business.
That the skill set that I
think so many people will get
in the future to succeed,
is how do I put a piece
of content, how do I make a white paper,
how many people here are B to B?
Raise your hands?
Great.
So, for your world, how
do you make a white paper
that's six pages deep, a
presentation on Skillshare,
then post on LinkedIn because Skillshare
is owned by LinkedIn and
when you use Skillshare
on LinkedIn, more people
organically see it?
Tactic ...
How do you make a Skillshare
that gives people value,
and it's not a sales deck
for somebody to sign up
for a free trial in your
landing page optimized
funnel, so that you then become
a client, it is just black
and white, an incredible
piece of information,
that all the construction
workers, that all the lawyers,
that all the CTOs, in
your target audience,
will get value out, and
basically what I'm saying
very carefully to all of you, is, I ...
When I wrote Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook,
and Thank You, Economy,
they were the two titles,
there was the third title
I never used, it was
called Guilt Marketing.
I basically believe that
the place that we're going
is, unless you guilt your
audience into doing business
with you because you provided
so much up front value that
you will get suffocated
over the next decade or two
of opportunities for the end consumer.
And so, what I do every
day is think about that.
And so, when I think
about guilt marketing,
provided value, where's
the under priced attention,
I used to call, this slide
used to say a year ago,
market in the year that you live in.
That we should be
marketing like it's 2016,
is what I would say.
Market in the year that you
live in, because so many
of you are spending time
and money on things that
worked much better in 2012, 2009, 2006.
So it was market in the
year that you live in.
What's happened is, with
the speed of updates
on Facebook and Instagram
and Snapchat and LinkedIn,
mobile devices, apps, VR,
AR, podcast, all this,
with the speed, I've now
changed it to day trading
attention, because you can't
just decide what you're
gonna do in January,
2017, and have success,
because too much is
happening during the year.
Right before Instagram
became the thing that
I think is the absolute
kind of current state
of the union of social
media, I was making content
that said Instagram was in trouble.
Snapchat was exploding.
And getting older.
Facebook was far more successful
under 30 than most people
realized, and I made a
video, you know, nine months
ago, or so, that said,
what's Instagram gonna do?
It copied everything
that Snapchat had, that's
what they were gonna do.
And it worked for them,
but it's fun for me to know
that that was day trading.
There's a video out there
that says Instagram's
in trouble, I stand here
today and say Instagram's
the most important.
So, I think the biggest
thing that I wanna make sure
in my key note, I get
across, is the themes
of the Q and A earlier,
which is yes and yes and yes,
and audacity, audacity,
audacity, you have to wrap
your head around the game
you're playing in, which
is the following.
There is more information
created now in 24 hours
than used to be created in
decades, only 50 years ago.
Like, let's just, stick with me here,
there is more content being
created in 24 hours, than
used to be created in the
decades of the 50s and 60s.
Now, do you feel as good
about your documentary?
Do you feel as good about your poster?
It gets hard when you actually
understand what the fuck
is actually happening here.
And so, what I believe
is happening for all
the business owners in
here, and entrepreneurs,
is that you need to wrap
your head around the mindset
of how you get yourself into a place
of accepting this, and
then acting on it, and how
does it become practical?
The reason I brought
up interns earlier is,
there's always supply and demand.
When something emerges,
other opportunity happens.
Amazon.
Scaring everybody in retail
in America and other parts
of the world, right?
Amazon is in the wine
business, they bought
Whole Foods, they now
have liquor licenses,
in every state.
Everybody at my dad's
company, Wine Libraries,
scared, wah.
Me?
Excited.
Why?
Not because I'm a character
or I'm trying to act cool.
Because I go on Amazon
site, and I find wines
that Amazon has, that
we're selling for less,
and then I send emails
to customers that say,
cheaper than Amazon, which is true.
And then from a branding
standpoint, it makes them
think we're incredible,
'cause nobody's cheaper
than Amazon on anything.
And even though Amazon is
gonna take market share,
they're not gonna take it from me.
In every single thing
that happens, I just said,
more content than 24 and
48 hours, than in decades.
Ooh!
Shit, how are people gonna watch my stuff?
Meanwhile, more creators
that are talented,
than we've ever seen before.
Every single person here
should write a blog post,
send an email, make a video,
or make an audio piece
of content, tomorrow, hiring
three content producers
as interns or the lowest
possible cost you can pay them,
based on the laws in
this country, tomorrow.
You immediately have a
media company at remarkably
low price, including if it's allowed free,
depending on the rules.
And that's what you
should be thinking about,
because if you do not wrap
your head around, that
you were a media company first,
I don't care what you do,
if you do not wrap your head around that,
you are a media company
first, comma, a lawyer,
comma, a designer, comma, a
sneaker salesman, if you do not
understand that you are a
media company, your business,
like the earlier questions,
you don't have to become
a personal brand, but
that means your logo of
your company, has to become
a brand that produces
content that actually has
value to the target audience
that you're trying to, now,
don't take it very direct,
let me give you an example.
I've a lawyer friend who's
starting a golf podcast.
He's starting a podcast
around golf, once a week.
He's interviewing golfers,
golf in the business,
but he's a lawyer looking for other people
to hire him as a lawyer.
His strategy is that the
people that are actively
hardcore about golf in America, are high
net worth individuals, who
can afford the law practice
that he provides, so that
if he makes something
that those doctors and
other business people
wanna listen to, golf, that,
because it's brought to you
by this law firm, he will
get the residual business.
Now my friends, this is
actually a tactic that
is hundred of years in the
making, and uniquely European.
Let me explain.
The Guinness Beer Company.
The Guinness Beer Company
started the Guinness Book
of World Records, because
pub sales were down and
they wanted them to grow,
and they did surveying and
realized that people talked
about trivia in the pubs,
and they decided to
create the Guinness Book
of World Records, so
that people in the pubs
would talk about the crazy
world records, reinforce
the Guinness brand, and then
order a pint of Guinness.
Michelin.
The reason you've gone to a
two or three star Michelin
restaurant, is because
almost 100 years ago,
the Michelin tire company
wanted rich people from London
and Paris to start
driving to the countryside
and stop by the gas stations
and use up their tires,
so they bought new ones, so
they started favorably reviewing
restaurants, hotels, and
inns, in the countryside,
and then making a book
that drove propaganda
and media to the rich in
those towns, and people
started going there
for the best foie gras.
(audience chuckles)
Media as marketing for business results.
What is old becomes new
and that in a framework
is the new strategy that I think has
the biggest upside for
every business in here,
regardless of what you do.
How you get people to pay
attention is the tactics
that I'm most excited about.
Whether that is Google,
whether that is Facebook,
whether that is something
else, once you establish
what your media is about,
and listen, by the way,
I'm standing up here, I
am very, very empathetic
that where I'm going right
now for the last five
to seven minutes, feels like, whew.
Like, if you're running your
business and I'm sitting
up here, and I'm telling
you, that you need to become
the BBC, or CBS, or,
you know, Sky Net, like,
I understand, however, please
take me up on this offer
and explore just a little bit.
If it starts as simple as
writing a very thoughtful piece
on your Facebook page
that you think the people
that could potentially be your customers,
would get value out of,
not you get value out of,
they get value out of,
you would be flabbergasted
by the opportunities and the
things that could happen.
The young man over there,
who asked 47 questions.
He listened to a tactic which I believe in
that everybody here
should pay attention to,
whether you're trying to
pick the people that you're
gonna give a poster for
free, or anything else.
The other arbitrage that
I'm massively excited about,
and the tactic that I
wanna give you here in
the key note, is DMing
people on Instagram.
There is a phenomenon going
on that is very intriguing.
You need to make a list
of the 50 to 100 people
that you want to speak to.
Whether you want them
to be the spokesperson
of your brand, whether
you want them to be your
first customer, whether
you just think they're
famous and you wanna be their friend.
I want you to make a list
of the hundred people
in the Nordics, in Europe, in
the world, that you would like
to have a relationship
with, for a business reason.
I want you to then search their profile
on Instagram.
If you do not find it,
go to Google and type in
the person's name, and the word Instagram
after their last name, so it shows up.
I'm being very tactical here.
Very mundane.
But, I believe attention
arbitrage, is also a way for,
where is the best business
development opportunity
for everybody in the room?
The best business development
opportunity in this room
is to not do what many people
do, which is spam people
on LinkedIn, because
nobody's paying attention
anymore.
It is to go to Instagram,
find their Instagram, some
of the people you want
will not be on there,
that's fine.
But the ones, the 83 of
the 100, the 47 of the 100,
that are, you DM them, direct message.
If you are not native to
Instagram or don't understand
that, there's a thing you
can do, you go to Google,
and you search, how do
I direct message people
on Instagram?
(audience laughs)
It will take your four
minutes, and listen, this
is like a fun thing to do,
'cause you have to understand,
this is what people ask.
People are like, be more
tactical in key note,
great, here you go.
This is what it is, it's
that basic, that's why,
but this is super important.
Because ...
You were blown away by what
happened when you started
doing it, right?
I'm blown away by what is happening on DM,
I became friends with
the Rock, and you know,
and all sorts of characters
that I never thought
I would ever interact with,
because people's attention
is on their direct message.
Now, most of you will
make the mistake that you
will go in for the ask
on your first writings.
You will DM, and you'll say, hey, Rock.
Can you wear my T-Shirt of my brand?
No, asshole, he will not do that.
But, if you look at their
last three or four posts,
if you spend ten minutes, don't forget,
you're only going after 100
people, this is the business
that you wanna build, and
see what they're about,
and you look, and you say, hey Rock,
I see you have a movie coming
out that you're excited about.
I wanna make some free posters for you.
You know, or whatever it may be.
If you bring value in
your first exchange on DM,
you will be stunned.
And I get this email 30
times a day, every day, just
read three of them before
I got back onstage,
of people who've made the
biggest business development
deals of their lives on
Instagram direct message,
in the last 30 days,
singularly for the same reason
that email worked so well,
in 1997, eight nine ten.
Because, how many people
here had email in 1999?
Perfect.
Do you remember what we
did in '99 with email?
We read every fucking email.
(audience laughs)
We do not do that anymore.
Supply and demand of attention.
Something emerges, we pay
attention, then a marketer
and marketers and business
people come along,
they ruin it.
And then we move on.
That is why I talk about
day trading of attention.
That, no matter if you have no money.
Or you have a huge business,
you know, I love when people
are like, if we get to Q
and A and they're like,
Gary, this is all great,
Facebook and Instagram, great.
But, my company does $38 million
and we grew 13% this year.
And we only do direct
mail and conferences.
What do you say about that?
What I say about that,
Hans, is what's wrong
with growing 74%, asshole?
(audience chuckling)
This is not about ...
What works or doesn't work, this is about
where is the upside to
create even more success
of whatever, you wanna
raise money for a charity,
this is not about, this
doesn't work, this does work.
This is about the tactics and the strategy
that is needed to
maximize the opportunity,
'cause here's the part
that I have not told you.
When I get introduced,
and they say, Gary built
his dad's business from three
to $60 million in five years,
and some people are like,
you know, a lot of people
don't know who I am, and like,
that sounds good, you know,
better than just some guy
yelling and cursing onstage.
(audience chuckles)
I sit on the side, and I
say, it should've been 200.
And it should've been 200,
because I was not day trading
attention in 1998, I was,
but I wasn't great at it yet.
I had Google.
I had Google, the first day
Google Adwords came out,
I bought every wine term,
they were five cents
a click, and I was converting customers
for 47 cents.
Who are worth fucking $30 for me.
What I didn't understand,
'cause I was a kid,
I just, I didn't know the
difference, is that I should've
poured all my money into Google, not print
and radio, and television,
and newspaper, which
is what I did, I spent much more on Google
than anybody else,
nobody knew what it was,
but if I took all that
money, and all that energy,
and I struck when it
was that good of a deal,
I would've had a much bigger
business and more success,
and if you are here to
have success and whatever
you're trying to communicate,
you need to understand that social media
which is a word that we
made up, so, let me say it
a different way, that the
current state of the internet,
attention is on Facebook
and Instagram, and LinkedIn,
and that the opportunity to
strike and maximize dollar
amounts out of it, is so
extraordinary, and the only thing
I wanted to say other than
that, is if you do it,
you will be like some
of the kids that raised
their hand right now and said,
this good thing happened,
and if you're not, you're
gonna raise your hand when
I'm in Copenhagen in seven years
talking about voice and AR,
and you're gonna say,
Gary, I'm listening to you
because you were here
seven years ago, and you
told me to do this, and I didn't.
And I watched other people do
it, and I didn't grow as much
or I lost, or I missed
my opportunity, and now
I'm listening to you this time.
I am saying this to put
a flag in the ground
to be historically correct.
Facebook advertising
is grossly underpriced,
and everybody here should
move as much of their money
into the platform as they possibly can,
and like, these two chicks are
high fiving, so I don't know
what is going on over there,
but I can't wait to find out.
(audience laughing)
But I promise you, they're
not high fiving because
they've run Facebook
ads and it didn't work.
(audience chuckles)
And more importantly, watch
this, this is important.
How many of you have
run Facebook ads and it
has not worked, raise your hands?
Should be plenty.
Raise your hands, raise
them high, don't be, higher,
raise them high, high, high.
It's important, thank you.
Running Facebook ads, and
it not being successful,
just so there's no confusion,
is not a Facebook issue,
it's a you issue.
You did not plan the media
properly, you did not
make the words and pictures work properly,
but this is not a debate.
This is data supported.
And I don't want to
hear that your customers
aren't on it, because that
doesn't exist, it just doesn't,
and I don't want to
hear that your industry
doesn't do well on it,
because it doesn't exist, it just doesn't.
We've sold jet engines on Facebook.
And I'm very tired of going
to meetings over the last
six months, where 70 year
old executives say to me,
for the first 30 minutes
of our dinner, can you
believe this Facebook?
They need to regulate it,
it changed the election,
the fucking Russians, and
Trump, and the Brexit,
and the fuck, and our
grandchildren, and this,
and all that.
And then we segue into their business,
and I start telling
them they need to spend
more money on Facebook, and they go, well,
there's no ROI there.
(audience chuckles)
Or my customer's not there.
So.
I'm making a very passionate
plea, because I want you
to win, for you to become
a practitioner, do you know
how many people here have
opinions on Facebook marketing,
but have never run an ad?
You've read an article in
the Wallstreet Journal.
Congrats.
You're a talking head.
You're not a practitioner.
You have an opinion off
of two conversations
with somebody you trust, but
you're not a practitioner.
You have an intuition, but
So.
If nothing else, go
spend $3,000 on Facebook,
with your money, you
do it, I don't need you
to outsource 26 year old Karen.
It's not a kids thing.
This is the most important
place where the attention
of our end consumer is, at scale,
and let me tell you one
great thing you have.
Because it is so
underestimated in the Nordics,
by the media companies, it's under priced,
because it's a market place.
But, the behavior of
the users in the region
are extraordinary in depth of attention.
Scroll time is slower, which
means there's more consumption.
Age is wider, it goes younger
here, and a little bit older.
And the companies are
not spending, your big
companies in these countries,
are not spending enough
money in it, so the prices are down.
How many people bought Google
Adwords in 2002, three, four?
Raise your hands.
For all the practitioners
here, and there's,
one more time, bought
Google Adwords, 2003, four?
Right.
For some of us here, go look,
I don't know if you're still
doing it, go look back
at right now, tonight,
what those words cost,
compared to 2002, three, four.
This is the moment, strike on it, and if
you don't understand it, don't outsource
to an agency, don't outsource
to your 21 year old
friend, start Googling on
how I make Facebook ads,
how I do creative for it,
what works, start testing, and start using
different variables.
Next.
How many people have 25
or more employees, raise
your hands?
Just trying to get a sense.
So, I wanna talk about
employees for a minute.
Culture.
This is managing yourself,
three person team,
ten 25, I'm a very big
believer in starting to follow
employees on social media,
and getting a better sense
of who they are.
I spend probably 90%
of my media consumption
just reading comments of
the content I put out,
and the people in my
community that read it,
and then I click their face
and go in a rabbit hole
and find out about them.
We are spending not enough time listening
to our employees, our
vendors, and our customers.
But the place where you
get the disproportionate
highest ROI is when you
listen to your employees.
Retention on the employee
level is imperative,
happiness is imperative,
'cause it leads to speed,
and speed is the
competitive advantage that
you have against your
competitors in your product
and service, and when nobody's
worried about politics,
or drama, they can worry about the work.
And so, I ...
Don't wanna spend too
much time on it, based
on the hands, but if you
were managing people,
and you've not had a sit down
with one of your employees
in the last six months
or a year, to find out
what they care about today,
whether that's money,
work life balance, title,
fame, and more importantly,
if you have an employee
that is actually seriously
important to your business,
which by the way means,
if you have one employee,
and they're the only employee
you have, then it's you
and them, and you do not
have an understanding of what drives them,
you need to have a two
and a half hour dinner
and create that glue, because
one of the biggest things
I see in businesses and
entrepreneurs, in failing,
is the over-reliance on
an employee that leaves
and then they have to start
all over for 18 months
or are completely crippled
by it, and the thing
that could've allowed them
to mitigate that disaster
is literally a conversation.
And if you're not a big
enough man or woman to hear
the feedback, well, your
company's gonna lose anyway.
So, not having the
conversation doesn't address
the issues that are happening
within your company.
So I implore all of you to start getting
very serious about this, because
if we're having a business
talk, the part about
business that we don't talk
enough about, is empathy,
for our customers,
but most importantly, for our employees.
None of your employees, I
love when people are like,
Gary, like, Gary, how
do I get my employees
to work as hard as me?
You don't, Frederick.
(audience laughs)
No employee should ever
work as hard as you
unless they have the same
equity in the company as you.
The audacity, my dad would
pay people $12 an hour
and want them to work as hard as he did.
That would always make
me laugh, and I know it's
very Russian and I get it, cultural, fine.
But it was super
interesting to me, I'm like,
Dad, they're making $12 an hour.
You own the business.
It's hard for them to care.
And so ...
I really, really, really
want to push empathy
for the humans that you're
doing business with,
because it's how you become
the best sales person,
it's how you become the
best manager, it's a default
of thinking about the
other person, not yourself.
Tactics, one more time,
it seemed like a lot.
One more time, I apologize,
but give it to me,
B to B businesses, raise your hands.
Let's talk about LinkedIn
for a little bit.
LinkedIn's ad product sucks.
And it's unfortunate,
because it could be so great.
And it could be so great
if they just literally
copied Facebook.
Like, if everybody here
could run ads with creative
against the titles of
people's jobs, you would have
the greatest tool of all time.
Because most of you in B
to B, are selling to people
that hold one of four to five titles.
It would be remarkable.
It's not there yet, it's got a high floor,
it's not a low floor
like Facebook and Google,
but I'm seeing things that
are making me ambitious
that the promise that
they were gonna be better
three, four years ago, is
finally maybe coming here,
I think Microsoft sees
it, I think it's coming.
Which is why, if you follow
me carefully, I've been
doubling and tripling down
on my LinkedIn content
myself, because I'm trying
to understand it better,
so I can give better advice to GE and SAP
and the clients we work with,
and so I highly recommend
that if you were a B to B
player, that you start allocating
real dollars to LinkedIn, even though
there is a way to target
people on Facebook,
let me ping you a very
tactical thing, B to B,
I want you to run two different tests.
LinkedIn, but let me give you
a very detailed ad product
on Facebook that I think
is enormously ROI positive.
On Facebook, how many
people here have spent
over $50,000 in Facebook
ads with them doing it,
not outsourcing it
through an agency, raise
your hand?
Okay.
Three.
Okay, so.
No, it's fine, it's what I
thought, and what I actually
hoped.
And that's a big number.
Facebook.
If you're not a
practitioner, you don't know
what the capabilities are, right?
You know, if you've never
opened a Swiss Army knife,
you don't know what's in it, right?
There is a segmentation in Facebook
called employees of, everybody
here in B to B can run
pictures, videos, or words
against people that are employees
of specific companies
in their Facebook feed.
If you understand how
powerful this is and what
you can do next, you'll
start unlocking some
incredible business opportunities.
By targeting the employees
of, and now you know
that your product is sold
to the CIO, or the CTO,
or the CFO.
Or the director of logistics.
Now, your copy, or the video you make,
starts with, does your CFO know?
Does your product managers understand?
Want to save time for your accountants?
If you literally verbatim articulate in
written or video form,
or picture form, the,
does the person in your
company that is this,
know about this, and then you
follow it with information,
a compelling video, a
how to, what have you.
We have seen ungodly
amounts of the following.
You run $1,000 in ads
against five companies,
and anywhere between
three and 74 employees
of that company forward that
post to the decision maker
and it is so extreme, and
unusual, that if the creative
is good and you jab instead of right hook,
that it has been one of the
greatest conversion rate
advertisings we've seen
in any shape or form
over the last half decade,
and it is a B to B Facebook
ad strategy.
So.
I can't wait for two months
from now, to get an email
from one of you, that actually ran this
and felt the results, so please
take that and run with it.
Look, I think that we should
talk about voice, because
I think that is something
that a lot of you
are gonna have to wrap your head around
going to the next 24 to 36
months, and this may be a place
where some of you have
the personalities where it
feels overwhelming to
catch up to everybody
on this social stuff, but
the excitement of being first
on the next thing is just
your personality trait
and you'd like to invest,
and that feels more exciting,
'cause you don't feel
dumb, and you feel smart.
I don't know what your insecurities
are, but I promise you,
here's a very important
thing to talk about.
Voice.
Besides money, health,
and religion, time is
the fourth pillar of the
things that drive us.
All of you do so many
things, like give up privacy,
to save a little time,
every day of your lives.
It's how we roll.
Uber.
Sold time, not transportation.
Many of the things you choose every day,
are you buying time back,
and you're willing to pay
the margin for the convenience.
I believe that audio in our
society is the next frontier,
because it is selling back time.
How many people here consume my content?
Raise your hands.
Raise them high, I want
everybody to look around.
'Cause I'm about to show you
something pretty interesting.
Of those people, how many of
you have started listening
more to my podcast in the last year,
and watching less videos, raise your hand?
This is remarkable.
Like, this is, thank
you, this is remarkable,
I would say that's 30 to 50%.
That same question just
a year earlier would've
been nonexistent.
What is happening, is
podcast, how many people here
are actively listening to a podcast?
Raise your hands.
It's incredible.
How many of you were not doing
that just three years ago?
Raise your hands.
Yeah, this is fucking it, and
this is day trading attention,
you've gotta watch these trends.
Sound.
Audio.
It's saving us time.
While you're commuting, while you're doing
something else, you're able to
consume content, and because
we underestimate the brain
and our ability to multitask,
you're able to do something else as well,
and are you completely holding everything?
No, but you start, you
know, it's the reason,
do you know how many
people should be dying,
based on how many people
text while they drive?
(audience chuckles)
This is an interesting
thought, I'm glad you guys
reacted.
The amount of people that should
be dying because of texting
and driving is enormous.
It's still higher than we'd like to admit,
but, the reason it's
not happening, is we can
do more things than people
realize at the same time.
And that is what sound is doing for us.
Podcasts.
But, the one that's gonna
save us way more time,
is what's coming up with
Alexa Skills and briefings
on top of the Amazon Alexa,
the one that's coming
from Google Home, the Apple Home pod,
and whoever else decides to enter, whether
it's Samsung or Facebook,
or somebody else.
Because when you get into a
place where you're brushing
your teeth, and you say, Hey, Alexa,
reorder my toothpaste, and
it's done, you're living
in a totally different world.
What do you guys do when
you're running around your life
and you remember that
you've gotta do something?
You take out your phone most likely,
and you do something, that
will normally take you
somewhere between 14
seconds to text somebody
to two minutes to write
a note or call somebody,
I don't know how you
roll, but I can tell you
that time is the thing that
all of you will trade on,
and the biggest white space
to change your business
in the next 24 to 36 months, is gonna be
about your investment to
understand how your product
and service can penetrate
the time quartum.
AKA, if in 2007, eight,
nine, you decided to be good
at Facebook and LinkedIn and Twitter,
you would have some of
the things that happened
to me, because I went all in.
You need to figure out
the same thing for time,
because the skills and
briefings, for example,
mark my words, five, six years from now,
everybody will wake up
and they will treat one
of these devices like the morning radio.
Remember, some of you woke
up with the Morning Radio
alarm, it would go off, and
your favorite morning show,
radio show, would start talking?
Your news and weather?
This is what you're device is gonna do,
you're gonna all download apps, skills, to
your voice device, and
your first seven minutes
of the morning are gonna
be curated with your bank
account, balance, with the
weather, with your favorite
sports teams update, with
the six most important
things in your business,
with your schedule.
You will listen, passively.
Now, you grab your phone,
go to the bathroom,
take a poop and look at your phone.
In the future, you will wake
up, and the first seven minutes
will start talking to you about things,
and you'll start interacting with it.
Alexa, change that meeting,
cancel that, tell Tyler
I wanna go to Copenhagen
three hours earlier.
It will be you and the machine.
And I highly recommend that
you start getting serious
about it.
Don't believe it?
Let me show you some
consumer behaviors that you
would find interesting.
How many people here,
remember, lying is the devil.
(audience laughs)
How many of you here, by show of hands,
now get annoyed when another
human being calls you?
Raise your hand.
Stand up.
Do me a favor, get up, I mean
it, I want everybody to see
how dramatic this is.
I see some of you didn't do
it yet, thank you up there,
look around, look up and down.
I'm gonna give you two
more, keeping staying up,
please keep staying up.
Keep staying up, I want
everybody to see this.
I'm gonna give you
another, I'm gonna ask you
one more time, in case you didn't hear it.
You are now upset, annoyed,
like, why would that person
call me, they can text me or email me.
You are genuinely, you react
poorly to another human being
calling you.
Look at this.
This is something that
was the most standard way
we communicated 36, 48 months ago.
Thank you.
More than half this room
is upset, literally,
(imitates phone buzz)
Come on, mom, fuck you, you know?
(audience laughs)
Text me, I'll call you on my time.
(audience applauds)
Listen.
Do you know how many people
here, because this is not
just 18 year olds, didn't
think they were gonna
get a cell phone, because
their pager was good enough?
I remember those days.
Do you know how many people
here were not gonna text?
'Cause texting was for kids?
Do you know how many
people here, 36 months ago,
when they saw emojis for
the first time, thought
it was the stupidest shit of all time?
But last night, sent a poop emoji?
(audience laughs)
We see new forms of
communication, and we resist them.
Until we realize they save us time.
That thumbs up emoji has
saved me a lot of time.
'Cause it's quicker for me to say, good,
instead of okay, 'kay, it's
just speed, and if you're not
paying attention, we are going so hyper,
and that is why sound,
voice, is the next frontier.
If you can figure out how
to build an Alexa Skill
that helps people with
your product and service,
that is a gateway drug then
to your overall product
and service, you know how
some of you have tried
to come up with free ebooks, free trials,
free this, free that, gateways into you?
If you are able to provide
that in sound, in voice,
if you then figure out
how, you have to understand
what happens, how many
people, anybody here build
an iPhone app when the
app store first came out?
Okay.
What happened, was there was a land grab.
There was not a lot of
apps, we all had the phone,
and so we went in there
and there was not as many
apps, and we pick the apps that we wanted.
There was a land grab.
There will be a land grab.
How many people here
have been in the Alexa,
the Amazon Alexa skill
store, how many of you
have been in there, raise your hands?
Right, about seven eight,
nine of you, right?
So you've seen, right?
It's interesting.
There's stuff there,
but not a lot of stuff.
Right?
This is the white space
that I recommend for
the people here that are
really trying to leap frog,
who are willing to,
like the first question,
eat shit for 24 to 36 months, stay around,
stay around, stay around,
and then let the market
come to you.
2009, ten, 11, 12, of
VaynerMedia, no company
wanted social media.
What's the ROI, what is it, it's stupid,
are talking about us on Twitter?
We don't want people talking
about us, don't put our,
but we stayed around.
We stayed around, and if
you're a stay around player,
if you're young, if you've
got the dollars to invest
and you're worried about
being at the mercy of Google
or other things and you want to diversify,
or if you just generally
believe what I believe,
which is that technology
is eating up our society,
and technology's not
a thing, it is oxygen.
Well, then you will get very serious about
the last ten minutes of
my rant here about voice
and you will go to Google,
and you will search
how to build an Alexa skill.
What's the difference
between an Alexa skill,
and Alexa briefing?
I'll give it to you
quickly, a briefing is dumb,
you just record something and it plays,
a skill is AI, and technology,
and you can interact with it,
it's more than app.
And so I think this is a
huge space, it's the one
I'm most excited about,
I have not invested
in startups for the last 15 to 24 months,
because I hate them all, I
think everything's overpriced,
I think everybody's an
entrepreneur, I don't think
anybody's interesting
anymore, I think it's all
club promoters that now
think they're entrepreneurs,
it just sucks.
But this is the first time I feel ready
to invest again, because
I went to Seattle,
I saw the incubator that
is only people building
on top of Alexa, it's creative
shit I'd never thought of,
I saw an app that you
say, Alexa, I'm starting
to read the book.
You read a child's
book, you start talking.
The boy ran through the street.
And Alexa starts making the sound of a boy
running in the street.
And as you're reading,
Alexa is complementing you
with surround sound.
He jumped in the puddle,
it started to rain.
You know, it's funny, I
don't think you can zoom in
but maybe you two can
see it, my goosebumps.
I sat there and is said,
oh my God, no child
will be read a book in seven years without
background noise
complementing the content.
Right?
You understand?
It's just so interesting.
There's just so much.
And let me tell you,
when your shirt's collar
is sound activated, and you,
when Alexa starts making deals
with Ralph Lauren, and your
collar is there, and anything
you think that you need to
create lack of friction of,
you just say, and it gets done.
We will all be addicted to
that, 'cause that is speed.
And if you could be the,
Alexa, I need a lawyer.
All of a sudden, Google
search is in trouble.
And so we live in a world
where we've accepted
the reality without
anticipating what's coming next.
Some of us lived in a
world where Yahoo was
the biggest search engine.
Some of us lived in a
world where Microsoft
was the company that we
had to regulate, because
they were too big.
We forget that this is
always gonna keep happening,
and the only thing that
your should be religious to
and it went away, is the
attention of the end consumer
and what's over priced
and under priced, what's
too early, VR, in my
opinion, is too early,
because you've gotta stay
alive for quite a long time
before people do it at scale.
Maybe I'm right, maybe
I'm wrong, we'll see.
But we have an incredible,
incredible decade
ahead of us.
I wanna remind everybody here.
Actually, how many people
are retiring in 12 years?
And I don't mean, you're gonna
come up with some big idea
crush it, and buy an island,
I mean you're fucking old
and you're finished.
(audience laughs)
12 years, raise your hands?
Okay, there's about six, seven of us.
I want to remind everybody
else that 12 years ago,
almost everything we
talk about did not exist.
Not Uber, not Facebook, not
Youtube, not the iPhone,
nothing.
And so, I implore everybody to understand
what I'm trying to do
in this talk, which is
change your mental strategy
of what you're gonna need
to be successful.
This is not about running
a simple Facebook ad.
This is not about learning
what an under priced
or over priced influencer is.
This is all those things,
but unless you have
the mindset of patience and empathy, and
really understanding the
reality of the marketplace,
there are people here, my friends,
there are multi-billion
dollar international companies
that will be out of business
in five years, because
of what's going on.
Do you think your eight
million dollar a year business
is safe?
The level of audacity of the entrepreneurs
and business people in here
who have a 50 million dollar
business and think they're good.
Because they've been good
for the last 15 years,
is extraordinary, and
it is going to create
a ton of carnage in the
entrepreneurial and business
landscape, because the
skill sets that it will take
to survive this next 15
years, are going to be
extraordinary.
Do you know how many of your
friends are out of a job
once people understand the power
of AI and machine learning?
I mean, do you understand
the ramifications
if block chain ever
actually hit full-scale?
It arbitrages out the need for countries.
Outside of weapons.
We are living through fucking crazy times.
And people think it's
like some silly update,
like the iPhone ten.
This is not, this silly
shit, this is the most
macro thing that has
happened to human beings,
in just 20 years of consumer
internet, we have watched
the internet tumble
dictatorships, create new dynamics
in the most powerful companies,
excuse me, countries,
in the world, take down the
biggest companies in the world.
Amazon has become the
biggest company in the world
or the potential biggest
company in the world,
by using Google ads.
The first seven years of Google ads.
That's who the biggest
advertiser was on Google ads.
Attention arbitrage.
Where is your customer, what do they do,
and why are you holding
up, what got you here,
instead of figuring
out what you need to do
to still be around.
The great mental flaw of this room.
Is that you put on a pedestal,
if you're successful,
what got you here,
without realizing that is
exactly what gives you no
chance to be successful
going forward.
For all the accolades
and all the cool things
going on with me, nothing
matters that I've done yesterday
and behind.
It is always having the level of humility
to know the customer's
right, and to be religious
about what the customer's
doing, and then providing value
to the customer.
Nothing else, ever, ever.
Ever.
Thank you.
(audience applauds extensively)
- That was a good one.
Gary, two years ago, at Elevate,
the main speaker, he was
talking about how only 5% at
max, leaves a room like this,
leaves a conference like
this, and really deploys
any of the knowledge that has been ...
- [Gary] That was a very optimistic dude.
- Thank you.
So, I guess I'm insane if I have a vision
that that number should be much higher.
Nonetheless ...
- It's not gonna be.
(audience chuckles)
It's not.
And I'm not trying to cut you
off, it's because what I'm
trying to do right now
is make the number be
two people to three people.
'Cause they're gonna get mad
that I'm calling them out,
and I'm trying everything,
love, hate, oil, vinegar,
honey, I'm trying everything
on you to do something
about this, but unfortunately,
people run their lives
on defense and fear.
- [Man In Audience] I'll fucking do it.
- Good.
(laughter)
And to me, I hope that you
bring this up, me doing that,
him doing that, the stakes are very high.
And I think the reason we
got tricked, was the world
didn't change for 70 years.
My friends, the growth
from the 30s to 2000,
were minor, when you understand
what the internet's done.
There were big, stuff happened.
But there's nothing like this.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
- But I guess you agree,
then, when somebody
actually does do it, then it's
also fair to celebrate it.
- Yes.
- And instead of just
asking for, to put the name
on the T-Shirt, but when
somebody has actually done it,
then it's also fair enough
to do something about it.
So ...
This guy that ...
We see ...
Here, okay, is Mez.
And Mez, I don't know if you
can say that he is the Danish
version of you, in terms of getting views,
he's pretty good, and in terms
of building a personal brand,
he's done pretty well for himself.
So, we really would like
to celebrate when people
do something.
So, among all the people who
have asked to get some time
with you, and get some time
in front of everyone here,
I think that Mez is a worthy candidate.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- So, Mez actually has, the
first question for you here,
this following up Q and A,
but if I know him right,
this is gonna turn into a
little bit of a weird thing,
I hope he keeps his
clothes on, because half of
the times, when he speaks in public,
half of it goes off.
But, Mez Myers.
(audience applauds)
- [Mez] Hello, Gary.
- How are you, my friend?
- I'd like to be myself when
- [Mez] I talk to you,
so if you don't mind,
and everyone else, I'd
like to drop my shirt.
- Yes.
Understand.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- [Mez] And I know this
might seem odd, but
as a 16 year old kid, I
wanted to be a speaker,
I wanted to go to schools
and help people build
their own self-esteem, I
really care about the youth,
and as someone who's suffered
from feeling different,
because I have this huge
fucking scar on my stomach,
you can't see shit, but it's
okay, but it's 24 centimeters,
and if you imagine an iPad.
In a vertical way, that's
the length of my scar,
which is a lot.
From a small boy.
So, I learned to dig
into the topic that you
really dig, which is
self-awareness, and I learned
a lot about myself until
I was capable of standing
at a stage and talking to
people, and when I finally
got that thing going, where, you know,
I got this shit!
I started to tell myself,
if I can't walk the talk,
social media wise, and
preach my message, just like
I do nowadays, then I'm shit.
So I did, and everything
escalated, and my brand
started growing, and going
from, I live in a basement.
Which is quite nice.
But, going from the basement
to becoming a national speaker
at schools was something
different, and the pressure grew
within the last five months, which I love,
because I got a lot of
speaking jobs, so that's nice.
I usually say I'm a stripper,
which is because I drop
my clothes.
Not at the principal's office,
like, (imitates knocking)
hello, but, you don't.
But, the point is, as the
pressure grew, how do you,
as an international speaker,
with all of your attention,
how do you cope with all of the pressure,
in terms of hate and
everything that goes on?
- Quite easily.
From a very basic thing.
I know what my intent is,
and I'm very grounded in it.
And I deploy enormous amounts
of empathy to my haters.
When somebody leaves a
comment on my Facebook
or anywhere else that I'm
a charlatan, or a snake oil
salesman, or my daddy
gave me the money to build
the liquor store and I
shouldn't be listened to,
I understand why they say that.
I know it's not true, and you
know, it feeds me in a very
good way.
And so, for me, to be very
honest with you, brother,
it's been very easy, because
when your intent is pure,
and comes from a good place, I think about
succeeding in one very simple story.
There are two ways, my friends, to build
the biggest building in town.
Step number one.
Just build the biggest building in town.
Step number two, build
a decent sized building
and then spend all your
time trying to tear down
everybody else's building around you down
so you end up being the
biggest building in town.
My friend, 95% of people
try to do number two.
But when you know you
can build the fucking
biggest building in town, you do that.
And so, because I know what my intent is,
I just don't value anybody's
opinion about me, including
my parents and wife and
children, more than I value
my opinion about myself.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
Before I leave, not directly
leave, I'd like to give
you something, Gary, this is
not wine, this is something
that has great importance
to me, because everything
I've done in the last two
years, building my brand,
has been built upon something different.
And those I give this to is
only to those who inspired me,
for example, you, to create
this concept in this way,
being me.
So, I'd like to give you something.
- [Gary] Fantastic.
- [Mez] I'd like to give you
a rubber duck, and this might
seem odd, but whenever
I talk, I talk about
becoming the ugly duckling,
standing up to yourself,
giving zero fucks about everyone else.
That's what I preach
to the youth at least,
that's why I'm naked.
- [Gary] Well, fuck, if I had
a six pack I'd be naked all
the time, too.
- Yeah! (laughs)
So I'd like to give you this, Gary.
- Happy birthday, nice to meet you.
- You too.
- You're gonna be a success.
That takes no courage,
if I was fucking ripped,
I'd be like, yeah.
(audience laughs)
Cool.
- [Woman] Cool.
And now, we've officially
gone into the Q and A.
- Yes, clearly.
- (laughs)
- Alright, and we have the
next question from Mez,
where are you Mez?
What?
- That was Mez.
- Oh.
- Next one.
Line, line.
- Oh, you missed one.
- One back.
One back.
- [Woman] One back.
- There we go.
Yep, good.
- [Woman] Women and technology, right?
Yeah, Leanie.
Oh, she was right here,
can we have a mic runner?
- Yep, she's coming.
- [Woman] Yeah, thank you.
- By the way, this lovely
lady who just brought the mic,
is wearing Vans sneakers,
if you do what I do
for a living, and try
to understand culture
and how things happen,
Vans 30 months ago, got
very aggressive in paying
Instagram influencers
to wear Vans, and that
is why Vans is back.
Period, end of story,
everything else is secondary.
That is why so many kids are wearing Vans,
for all the people that
are wondering why they see
more Vans today, period, end of story.
(audience chuckles and applauds)
Just trying to help, just
trying to make you see
that it's happening.
This is not coming.
I'm sorry, go ahead.
- [Leanie] It's okay.
First of all, thank you, Gary, for coming,
I'm a big big fan, and I've
been listening to your podcast
for more than a year now.
Hours and hours and hours, which
makes it a little difficult
actually to ask questions because ...
- Right, 'cause you know all the answers.
- [Leanie] I know all the answers.
But before asking the
question, I just wanted to
thank you, to say thank
you to Casper for actually
taking the risk bringing you here.
For all of us in
Copenhagen, small country.
So, I think we should actually
clap it up for Casper.
(audience applauds)
And actually that is along
the lines of the question
I've formulated up there,
is because I think Casper
must've suffocated some
excuses to do what he's done,
and I'm working on all my
excuses, but, and I see you
working on people's excuses.
- A lot.
- So ...
- [Leanie] Not being Gary
V, how can I sort of inspire
people around me to work on their excuses?
- By, you know, it's funny,
long before I was Gary V,
this is what I was doing
for my high school friends,
who were doing stupid things
like drugs and alcohol
or driving drunk, because
they wanted to act cool
in front of somebody, this
is just about self-esteem.
It's so simple, it's almost
overly emotional for me.
This is about self-esteem.
The way I choose to do it, and
you know this is how I do it,
is I go directly at it.
Every one of us can think
of somebody we care about
right now that's just not doing it right,
and all you have to do is
sit them down and tell them
they're not doing it right,
but we don't wanna do that,
because we'd rather not
short-term hurt their feelings,
and let them fail long-term,
which is remarkably crazy,
if you give a fuck about somebody.
So what can you do as not Gary V?
Have the actual conversation,
and tell your sister,
your mom, your uncle, your
aunt, your child, your
best friend, the next
time they come up with
an excuse, that it's a fucking excuse.
The reason I say the thing
that if there's anybody
that ever looked like you
that made it, then there's
no excuse, is 'cause I believe it.
You know, it's really hard,
you're in an argument,
and your friend tells
you, that's great, Gary,
but both my parents were alcoholics.
And that really fucked me up.
Right now, you're on the defense,
that's a good first punch
by them.
I'm like, cool, we don't need to use me.
If anybody has ever been
successful, that had two alcoholic
parents, which by the
way, I know of three.
Well, then, now what's your excuse, Karen?
We are just so interested
in blaming everybody else,
and excuses, 'cause we don't wanna take on
responsibility.
And somewhere a long time
ago, I went completely,
I only, you know, I think
everything is my fault?
Like, all of it?
Like, I think it's weirdly
cloudy outside right now,
and not nice out, my fault.
(audience chuckles)
Like, his scar, my fault.
Like, I fucking just
default into my fault.
And everybody tries to do everything else
the other way.
And let me tell you how
good life becomes when you
take on responsibility.
It gets real good.
Some of you, and there's a
lot of you that follow me.
You know why I keep
bringing up the last scene
of 8 Mile, the Eminem
movie, how many people
have seen that movie?
Great.
The last scene, they go into the battle,
he makes fun of himself
the whole time, because
it leaves the other person with nothing.
The leverage is in being
accountable of everything.
The leverage is exposing your weaknesses,
I proudly talk about
passing on Uber twice,
being a DNF student, you
know, I proudly talk about
my shortcomings.
Right?
I can't wait for more
bad things to happen.
I mean it.
Because I will talk about
them, because, what?
You're so fucking perfect?
Fuck you.
Right?
So, how do you do it?
You have the conversation, and you realize
that you're doing a disservice
to the people you love
the most by holding your mouth shut.
Because you're not willing
to deal with the short term
conflict.
(audience applauds)
- [Woman] Stoem.
Where are you?
- Stoem?
- [Woman] Are you here?
Okay, then I will ...
Then we will take the next one.
- Okay.
- Yeah?
- [Woman] What?
(audience members shouting)
- Oh, it's a good question?
- What's the question?
- Good.
- Okay, then.
- Let's do it.
What is it?
- [Woman] Do you have a mentor
yourself, or master mind
group of people you
meet, on a regular basis,
and discuss business matters with?
- Nope.
(audience laughs and applauds)
- [Woman] How's that for a good question?
- And this is interesting,
I'm trying to figure out
if I can bring you value in this.
Nor have I ever.
My mentor is you.
It is far better for you
to look up to the 31 people
that leave comments on your
shit, than to watch me more.
My mentor is the market.
My mentor is your attentions
and your behaviors.
So, I've, outside of my
parents, I don't know anything
about any business person ever.
I've read five books in
my life, I'm not part
of any group, I consume no content.
I consume the market.
Which is why I see these
things, because I watch
what you do.
You know how Wikipedia
and Youtube, you start
watching something or reading
something, and three hours
later, you're learning about
like, redheaded Eskimos?
Right?
That's what I do with people.
I get a lot of comments now.
70% of it is I'm the
greatest fucking thing
of all time, which feels nice.
10% of it is I'm a piece of shit.
And then 20%, there's
people trying to leave
something thoughtful.
Of that 20%, 5% of it is thoughtful.
They figured it out, they
got it, and then I click
their face.
Who else do they follow?
Oh, they're getting tricked by
that one, but they got this,
why?
Oh, why are they taking
pictures of music festivals?
Why are they drinking beer?
Why is craft beer moving?
What, and seven hours
later, I have a pulse
on something that's
happening in the ecosystem.
I didn't invest in
Facebook, Twitter, Tumblr,
by accident.
I'm not hanging out with the hip-hop stars
that are the next Kanye,
and Drake, by accident.
I'm doing real hard core research
of the thing that matters.
You're my mentor.
(audience applauds)
- [Woman] Leannie.
- [Leannie] That's me again.
- [Woman] That's you again!
Amazing.
- Listen, you're super fucking talented.
Own it.
How do you bring a plan ...
I can read it, how do you
bring, or plan on bringing,
your own children's perspective, meaning?
- [Leannie] Well, you talk
about a lot about perspective
and gratitude.
- Yes, yes.
- [Leannie] And I guess in
Denmark, we're sort of all
very privileged, and you
talk about your own children
almost having a sort of a, you
know, chip on their shoulder
coming now, with you, in the, you know,
- Yeah, 'cause the level of
disrespect I have for them
is extraordinary.
(laughter)
No, really, I mean like, you know, that's
a natural reaction to people
that are handed a lot of stuff,
it can go one of two ways.
- [Leannie] So ...
So, my children are privileged.
- Yep.
- [Leannie] How do I
give them or bring them
the perspective, the gratitude?
They're eight, ten and twelve, sorry,
eight, twelve, fourteen.
- This is the great
challenge for so many of us.
So, first of all, there's
something that I watched,
this is something I've
been passionate about
long before I had them.
Now, it really fucking matters.
And it will matter, you
heard me earlier say,
forget about what I'm
doing, how they come out
is going to be my legacy, so I care.
First of all, for everybody in here,
you need to wrap yourself
around something most parents
don't wanna wrap their
head around, which is,
you can't fake environment.
The amount of rich friends
I have who send their kid
for four days to Africa to
build a school, and think,
now, they're grounded,
is fucking ludicrous.
You can't fake environment.
If you are privileged, you are privileged.
If you are not, you are not.
The great gift and curse for all of us,
if we have too much,
or we have too little.
Then your DNA, and
parenting, and environment,
take over, on which path you decide.
What I'm doing, is,
there's a couple things
that are my religious ten
commandments, and I'm sticking
to those and everything
else I'm unemotional about.
So number one.
Kindness.
Kindness is non-debatable.
If Xander and Misha ever deploy
meanness on somebody else,
especially based on how much
money mommy and daddy made,
I will physically punch them in the face.
That's number one.
Kindness is not debatable.
Number two.
They have to really
love what they're into.
I have no interest in my
kids being an entrepreneur.
I have no interest in
my kids being a showman.
I want them to be what the
thing they love the most is.
Number three.
There's no such thing as
fourth place trophies.
All these privileged
kids are being protected
from hurt feelings, by
parents today, which is why
they're gonna suck.
(audience chuckles)
Because in real life,
you come in fourth place,
and eight place, so in my upper east side
of Manhattan, culture,
there's a lot of eighth place
trophies and everybody's
fucking great at everything.
I tell little kids that are six, you suck.
(audience laughs)
Their parents get mad at me, but I'm like,
Ricky sucks at golf!
So, no make-believe.
And then number four,
almost everything else does
not matter.
Number five, update the
list as soon as I feel like
I have to, in real-time,
as soon as I see something
that makes me have to update the list.
- [Leannie] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
- [Woman] Casper.
Can we get a mic runner to Casper?
You look surprised, yeah.
- [Casper] So, what
personal skill, and not
a business skill, do you
believe to be the most
crucial for anyone to
develop in order to catapult
one's business to the next level?
- Empathy.
I can't let it go.
I need you to have it.
I don't know how to
develop it, don't go buy
bullshit courses that teach
it, you know, before you do it,
be thoughtful, but if you have
empathy, you have everything.
It's just so big.
It's so big.
It makes you incredible at sales.
I'm a great all time sales
man, 'cause I'm empathetic.
I basically can't even
live my life without,
I watched my mother, and she has it too,
but we have different,
obviously, we're different.
She's the centerpiece
of every single person
that knows her.
Her empathy for everybody
becomes a leverage of everybody
needing her.
And she took it in a way,
and I got the benefit
of watching it, that I think allowed me
to find a little bit of a
better lines in the sand
where to stop and start,
and I'm different,
in a lot of ways, businessey
and competitive, and
we're different, but when
you have empathy, you
have everything.
And I just, you know,
there's a lot of things
I care about, right?
Gratitude, it surely makes
you positive, if you have
perspective on that, but
if I had to pick one, in
the way you're asking, it's empathy, man.
If you just, like, all
of you care about you.
Not your customers, not your
employees, not your vendors,
and I get it, you have to
take care of your family.
I get it.
But it's the way, if you
care about them more,
and figure out what's
left for you and what
to do with it, you will have
for the rest of your life,
and I'm sure it's very
Biblical and very faith-driven
and very altruistic, it's, doesn't make it
any less true.
Empathy.
(audience applauds)
- [Woman] Yes, and we
have gotten some notes
while you were speaking.
Li-li-don Keh-lu-ta.
Yeah!
Can we get a mic runner to him?
- All the way back?
Yep.
- [Lilidon] Hello, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Lilidon] I'm good, thanks.
You?
- Great.
- [Lilidon] (chuckles)
I have a question about
passive income, and I wanna
know what kind of trends
do you see for a person
interesting in that?
I don't want to be stuck
in office nine to five
for the rest of my ...
- Well, passive income comes in two forms.
97% of the form is the
douchiest, shittiest thing
on earth, and 3% is the
tried and true thing
that has actually created
passive income in the history
of mankind.
So, let's find out which side you're on.
How are you thinking about,
when you say passive income,
do you mean some, what do you mean?
- [Lilidon] I mean not having
to work all day long ...
(audience laughs)
I wanna be on a beach in
Mexico instead of being
in an office in Sweden in cold November.
- Are you being serious right now?
- [Lilidon] Yes, yes, I'm serious.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauds)
The quickest way to not
be on a beach in Mexico
is to think that passive income exists.
It's a bad mindset.
I really believe that.
I think the reason so many
scumbuckets are making
so much money, is because
you're buying stupid fucking
courses over and over, thinking
there's some fucking magic
formula for passive income.
Passive income looks like this.
You take money that you
can afford to go to zero,
and you put them into two
places that have historically
created passive income.
Public markets that you
don't care if it goes
up and down and you just wait
to the end, or real estate,
and you hope that your
real estate area doesn't
get crushed.
Everything else almost doesn't exist.
- [Lilidon] I'm thinking
more of real estate,
because I've been
involved in it in Sweden.
- Love it.
- [Lilidon] And for all the Danish people,
it's pretty like the
government is very restricting
on creating a real estate business, it's
a lot of taxes, it's really
hard if you don't have
the money in the beginning.
- So shouldn't you work
your face off to get money,
not buy dumb shit like
a watch and put it into
the real estate?
- [Lilidon] (chuckles)
Yes, I should.
(audience laughs and applauds)
- Okay.
Look, look, you know ...
And I think you know,
and I'm happy I could see
your energy, I'm so
passionate about this issue.
There are people that
are ripping people off
at the level of hundreds
of millions of dollars,
because they're selling this
dream, because they made
a video with pretty girls in
a beach in the background,
and are making people spend a
thousand, two, it's breaking
my heart.
Passive income doesn't exist
and anything that starts
with I don't want to work,
is already a problem.
What you need to do, is,
I understand, I don't want
to work in an office or
something I'm not passionate
about.
What I, the best way to make
money, is to make less money
than you're making now,
enough to still live,
'cause you gotta live.
Around something that
does interest you, because
you wake up eight years
later, and it's something,
good is actually happening.
So, it's not, the, everybody
wants to make it the
extreme of, I'm sitting
in my job, I hate it,
this sucks, all the
way to beach in Mexico.
But there's a real
in-between, which is why
I wrote Crush It, which is at
night, when you're done with
your shit job that is paying for the life
that you have to live right
now, A, you don't take some
of that money and buy
dumb shit like 17 beers
watching the World Cup.
What you do instead is
you work on something
on the internet that costs
you nothing to start,
save all those dollars,
build something for yourself
over seven years, and then transition from
the shit job, to your own business.
That's passive.
- [Lilidon] (chuckles)
Okay, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Woman] And now for a
very exciting question.
Yaka Bierman!
Yeah, can we get a mic runner up here?
Thank you!
I'm looking forward to hearing this, Gary.
- Yeah?
- [Woman] Yeah, very much.
- Okay, good.
- It's an exciting question.
- [Yaka] Don't put pressure on me, now.
- Yeah.
- Yeah (laughing).
- [Yaka] Hi, Gary.
- Hey, brother.
- [Yaka] Hey, I've been
following you since
2010.
- Thank you.
- [Yaka] Been applying both Crush It
and the Thank You, Economy,
and it's really changed
everything I've done.
- Thank you.
- [Yaka] I published a book this year.
- Congrats.
- In doing the content
- [Yaka] Marketing ever since,
with the Guilt Marketing
perspective.
I wanna show it to you
later, because I've tried to
give you some attention
in the book, even though
it's on strength training.
- Thank you.
- [Yaka] My question for today
is, you have been talking
a bit about meditation, and
mental practice as being
the next big thing, if
you would call it that.
But I kind of feel like it
seems that you're a bit afraid
of doing it yourself.
- I am.
- [Yaka] For what, and why?
- Because my head is perfect,
and I don't want to fuck
with it.
(audience laughs and applauds)
I'm being dead serious.
I could be completely
out of my mind, but I am
so happy ...
Always.
That the thought that
meditation may do something
and open up some tunnel
in my brain, that takes,
when you are 100% happy ...
The fuck would you fuck with that with?
(audience laughs)
But ...
- [Yaka] But, as you
said, it's good to grow,
but why not grow even
more, in a business sense?
- You're right, what I'm
scared of is, I genuinely think
it's 100, and unlike
business, 100% of something
doesn't have 101.
- [Yaka] But what if it's 80?
- That's a great question.
But, in a world where my
intuition has been everything
for my entire life and my
entire intuition is like,
fuck you, I'm gonna listen
to me, I'm gonna listen
to me.
(audience laughs)
That's why.
That being said ...
As you may know, 'cause
you've been paying attention,
I did meditate twice
now, once in a company.
(audience laughs)
I'm telling you.
I'm telling you my truth,
I mean, this is, you know,
I invested in a company called Inscape,
it has a studio in New York and an app.
And then I did a podcast where
Dan Harris made me meditate
on the show.
It didn't go well.
(audience chuckles)
I tried to shut off, but I couldn't.
I'm making some jokes,
on a very serious kick,
I'm not super duper scared
of it, there's a lot of truth
in what I just said,
but I'm not against it,
I've already done it twice,
I could see myself meditating
in the future.
I genuinely think I'm
meditating in real time always,
I really mean it.
I'm, I'm pulling, you
know, some of you that
are meeting me right now,
I'm a real enigma, I'm
pulling in a lot of
contradictions, I'm carrying
a lot of conflicting thoughts.
I desperately care about you so much
that I'm reading every
one of your comments,
yet I actually don't
give a fuck about what
you're saying.
Right?
Like, I'm doing a lot of
weird shit, and I feel like
it's creating that balance and I think
when I audit the market
of what meditation can do,
it lets people close out the
noise that's bringing them
into negativity, reset,
refresh, whatever it may be.
But, you're absolutely
right, on the record,
in the same way that health fitness became
an incredible industry
over the last 30, 40 years.
I believe that mental fitness, meditation,
is going to be quadrillion
drillion billion trillion
dollar industry, apps and
studios and the T-shirt
brand and the headband, and food that is
enables better meditation,
and every cockamanian thing
that every fucking
entrepreneur comes up with,
meditation is going to
be one of the massive
commercial plays, and
then, people that have
been in it for a long time in the far east
and India are gonna be super
pissed, 'cause they got
commercialized.
(audience chuckles)
And that's fine, because
more people, I'm excited
to watch it, because I
think a lot of people are
gonna be helped, because
we're just starting to have
the right conversation with
each other around mental
illness, and for some of
us, like myself and others
who've been around people they
love so much that have it,
and you didn't know it
for all those years,
you just thought it was a bad attitude or
a bad personality, I'm
excited that we're gonna
start putting this in the
right place in our culture
over the next 50 years,
and I think a lot of people
are gonna be helped.
- [Yaka] Also, because
you've been talking a bit
about Silicon Valley also,
with the problems with
suicide and so on, in
that sense, it would ...
- And to be honest with you,
it's more entrepreneurship
than Silicon Valley.
The biggest fear I have right
now with entrepreneurship
is it's such a personal loss.
Guys, there's a very
big difference between
your business failing and
everybody watching it,
and you getting fired from a job.
And if you don't have the
makeup to being an entrepreneur
and dealing with that, and
you were meant to having
a job, but you're doing
entrepreneurship 'cause
it's cool right now,
you are gonna struggle.
And I'm scared.
'Cause I get the emails every day.
I'm not guessing.
I'm not predicting.
I get 15 to 20 emails a
week that allude to suicide,
that tell me that a video they saw,
huh, Mons, have you gotten
an email about people,
emailing you and saying they
were gonna commit suicide
Thursday but they saw a video?
- [Mons] Quite a lot.
- That's right.
Now, whether they're
telling the truth or not,
even if one in the
thousands of emails that him
and I have gotten, even if one
of them is telling the truth,
think about what that feels like.
We have to have
straightforward conversations,
no fourth place trophies, you
gotta tell people the truth,
because we're playing fake,
and then when real shit
happens, people are not equipped to deal.
(audience applauds)
(makes farting noises with mouth)
- [Woman] Kirsten!
Yeah?
So right here, can we get
a mic runner over here?
Thank you.
- [Kirsten] Thank you, and
thank you for allowing me to
add in the question last moment.
- [Woman] It's a good question.
- [Kirsten] I'm the head of
sales at an old family company
here in Denmark, called Flensted Mobiles.
- One more time?
- [Kirsten] I'm the head of
sales at a family company
here in Denmark, for
three generations, we've
been selling mobiles to the world, art,
basically.
- Art?
- [Kirsten] Yes.
Not phones, but pieces of
art hanging from the ceiling.
- Amazing.
- [Kirsten] And for many
years, our sole customers
have been brick and mortar shops.
- (chuckles)
- [Kirsten] Yes.
See where I'm going
with this, because now,
we have more and more customers who either
set up their own online
shop, or even start
dealing by Amazon.
So now, my wholesellers are calling me up
saying, that guy is
selling into my market,
you gotta stop him.
This one is dumping the prices.
Stop them.
And legally, I can't,
and I'm not even sure
I want to.
But I want to ensure the
coexistence of the two.
The online shop, and the
brick and mortar shop.
- It won't happen.
You don't have enough
leverage to make them coexist.
- [Kirsten] Yeah?
I was hoping you might, you
know, provide me one tip
in a way I could support
my old and faithful
customers, some of them
don't even have email.
- By telling them to get fucking email.
(audience laughs)
I'm trying to help you.
- [Kirsten] Yeah, I know.
- 'Cause if you hold on
even 1%, you're gonna lose.
And I can see you have good intent.
Tell old man John
- To get a fucking email.
- Well, to be honest, we want
- [Kirsten] To support our old customers,
and we don't even have our
own online shop, because
this old family company
didn't want to compete
with our own customers.
- I understand.
- [Kirsten] But I guess I'm realizing
that we need to ...
(laughs)
- There's a very good reason
third generation companies
go out of business.
They hold the past on a higher pedestal
than the current.
You got the answers,
listen, I'm empathetic.
You cut into a third, you
not being a family member,
in a third generation family
business, that has had
success for 100 fucking years,
the problem is, tough shit.
- [Kristin] (chuckles softly)
I'll tell them.
- You got it.
(audience laughs and applauds)
You know?
The quicker, you know what you can do?
Something you can do is create a workshop
for all your old-school
customers, and bring in speakers
that are talking, you're
gonna have to educate them,
that's you doing the
noble thing to help them,
but you can only do so much.
But you're gonna have to
educate them, and you're gonna
have to start sending
signals that you're not
gonna protect them.
'Cause they're playing
defense and think you will,
and the quicker you don't
play fourth place trophies,
we have to trade on merit.
It's too bad.
But I wanna remind you,
that those shop owners,
who are about to go out of
business, they put somebody else
out of business.
Why are we protecting the
current establishment?
They put the people that
used to sell art outside,
out of business.
Right?
Like, anybody who's winning
now, means they took it
from somebody else.
People like, we've gotta
protect supermarkets.
Why?
Why do you think they're
called "super" markets?
'Cause there used to be markets.
And then they came along
and made them super,
and put the other fuckers out of business.
(audience laughs)
Right?
And one day, somebody's
gonna say, we've gotta keep
Amazon alive.
That will happen.
And to that person,
'cause I'll put it on film
right now, fuck Amazon.
They had their time, and now
it's time for Schmamazon.
(audience laughs)
That's it.
(audience applauds)
- [Woman] Now, isn't it amazing
that you came to Elevate?
Maybe we will save a 100 year old company,
just because you came here today.
Now, to another question that your answer
might help, that he can
become a 100 year old company.
Thomas Sinding?
Where are you?
- [Thomas] Yeah.
- [Woman] Yeah!
Microphone, over here?
Thank you.
They're really snappy, aren't they?
Yeah.
- [Thomas] First of all,
I run a small company,
two persons, we do a lot content creating.
I've been, for the past year,
working with a Danish athlete,
creating his content.
He's a race car driver,
driving LeMons and stuff
like that.
We're doing it for free for
him, for a whole year now,
and it's about time that stuff happen.
- Yep.
- [Thomas] What is your ...
- Ask him for money.
- [Thomas] Yeah, and I know
that, but my thought is
should I be very honest
with him and ask him,
how much do you earn?
I'm thinking about, can I get five or 10%
of what you earn ...
- Are you out of your fucking mind?
- [Thomas] What?
- You're not gonna get five
to 10% of what he earns!
- [Thomas] I don't know!
- No shit you don't know!
- That's why I'm asking you!
- So, let's start over.
How much do you want?
- [Thomas] I want to make a living?
- With respect, off of one fucking guy?
- [Thomas] No, because
actually, I work full time,
or more than full time, at my day job.
- Understood.
- [Thomas] And I work like,
30, 35 hours in my own company.
Like, almost no sleep,
and stuff like that.
- Do you have any sense
of what other people are
charging personal brands for content?
- [Thomas] Nope.
- How much output are you giving him?
- [Thomas] I'm giving him
almost all of his output ...
- What is it?
- [Thomas] We've done
ten episodes on Youtube,
with like, ten minutes of content ...
- Good stuff.
- [Thomas] I think it's good quality.
- Let's assume it is.
How about Instagram?
- [Thomas] All of his posts, almost.
- How many?
- [Thomas] Like, five a week.
- Five a week, okay.
And what else?
- [Thomas] Facebook.
The real old school
PR, like press releases
and stuff like that.
- Why are you doing that?
(audience chuckles)
- [Thomas] Because some
of his, in Denmark,
we still read the papers
and stuff like that.
- No, I understand.
(audience laughs)
Everyone still reads the papers.
- [Thomas] Yeah, but, the
paper's also online now,
so, it's ...
- But when you say press
release, you're writing
a press release, or
you're updating his fans
on what he's doing, in
written form, on Facebook?
- [Thomas] Both.
- Okay.
What else?
- [Thomas] Like, I don't know ...
- Do you engage, do you
guys reply on his behalf
on Twitter?
- [Thomas] Yeah, not on
Twitter, but on Facebook
and Instagram, yes.
- Okay.
- [Thomas] And emails.
- And how many hours are
you guys putting in a month?
- [Thomas] I don't know.
Maybe 30, 40 hours?
- And you and your partner, or just you?
Overall hours.
- [Thomas] Overall hours.
Like, 40, or something like that.
- So, you know, I think ...
You know, $1,500 to $5,000
a month is what you need
to be thinking about.
- [Thomas] And then one
more thing, you talked about
the DM guys on Instagram.
Actually did that yesterday,
but it didn't work out.
- How many times did you do it?
- [Thomas] Just once, and the guy's name
was Gary V.
- Yeah.
Gary V got 4,000 DMs yesterday.
- [Thomas] I know.
- I know, I'm kidding.
- Just to tell you.
- But, I'm glad you brought
it up, 'cause I want
people to hear this,
'cause we brought it up
earlier.
- [Thomas] Yeah.
- You just gotta keep, D
Rock emailed me four times
to offer me to make a free video.
Imagine if he stopped at three.
That's the answer to that question.
- [Thomas] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
- [Woman] Now we need to
hear from the Hungry E,
it's just signed E, who
wants to get hungry again?
Is that you?
- My God.
- I didn't picture you as
- The Hungry E, bro!
- [Woman] No!
- Can we get a mic runner?
- Mic?
- [Woman] Can we get a mic runner?
Thank you!
Take it away.
- How are you?
- [Irvin] Thanks, hi.
I'm Irvin.
- Pleasure.
- [Irvin] So, I came to
Denmark five years ago
with almost nothing, and
I got to work really hard.
I got to work really hard, just night jobs
and so on.
Then I start volunteering
a lot, and kind of after
five years, I made it, so
to say, in my own terms,
and now I find myself not working anymore,
from two to seven to night,
and I'm a bit concerned,
that, is this it?
How can I push to go forward?
- Are you worried that you're
content and you're trying
to get the spark?
- Yes.
- Maybe you need to do something else.
Maybe you're content in what got you here.
- Yes.
- Why am I great?
I built one of the largest
liquor wine stores in America.
And I did it.
And I was like, wait a minute,
the liquor laws are bad.
This doesn't feel like it's it.
I made it.
You know.
I did, I started a Youtube show.
Maybe you made it, thank God, in what you,
I don't know what you do.
Maybe you need to do
something completely different
and have the thrill that
I always have, which is
the climb is much more fun than the stuff.
It's what, it's that
great guy in the back,
the good-looking guy with the beard.
I want him to love the
process, not the idea of
the Mexico beach.
Maybe you're like me and you
love the process so much,
that now that the process
is not fun, even though
the money's there, even though
the opportunity's there,
you're missing the spark, the climb.
You know why I love
coming to southeast Asia
or Nordic, I wish none
of you knew who I was.
That's the climb.
People think it's the
other way, I don't want
anybody to know who I am.
That's actually probably my
biggest fear, is the game
of getting known, you
know, I plan on getting
to all 7.3 billion of you.
And then when that's
done, it's gonna be like,
fuck, do I have to go to
Mars, or, you know, like,
so, I think that I have a
feeling it might just be
that you're looking for a
new process and a new start
from the bottom to build up.
- How can I know what to choose next?
- Just pick something.
(audience chuckles)
It's a really interesting question.
I really believe that,
like, I don't know you,
right, but there's things
that are on your mind.
I would start with
interests outside of work.
Like, if I would start something, like
if you're into video
games, I think esports is
about to be one of the
biggest industries in
our society over the next 30 years.
Maybe you don't know anything
about esports, but you like
video games, here's
the chance to start ...
- [Irvin] I was looking into it, actually.
- Yeah, so now, from seven
p.m. to two in the morning,
for the next four months,
you learn everything about
esports, and then you
decide what you wanna make.
I think you want the
process, which is incredible,
because it's gonna lead
to a lot of success,
which is why you've probably figured out
how to win in five years, because you love
the process, so you
were willing to eat shit
and work at night, and be
patient, and that's why
you got somewhere, now you
got somewhere and you're like,
wait a minute, fuck, you're
calibrating, you're young,
you need to go out and
do other new processes.
If you've got complete flexibility,
I would do it around
other things you like.
Music, sports, beer, like, I
don't know what your interests
are outside of it, but you
start there, because that's,
I mean, Vayner sports,
me and AJ are building
this sports agency.
It's a real fun thing, like,
we're gonna kill everybody
and it's gonna be a huge
company, and it's fun
to talk about football,
like, we know about trades
before they come out in public, you know.
We like it.
So, I think if you can do it
around something you like,
I would go and look in the,
discover the business behind
the things that you're interested in.
- [Irvin] Thanks a lot.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
- [Woman] Yes?
Mason?
Hm, can we get a mic runner, thank you.
- Mason, Mason, Mason.
- [Mason] Hello, how are you, Gary?
- I'm really well, you?
- [Mason] I never thought
I'd be nervous talking
to a guy, but ...
(audience laughs)
- That's super flattering.
- [Mason] I just wanna
thank you for two things.
One of the things, you changed my life.
And the two years ago, one
year, one and a half year ago,
I was just sitting at home, doing videos,
professional videos,
and I thought that that
was gonna change my life.
I'm an artist, first
of all, I learned to be
a media company first.
That you talked about,
and I had so many videos,
like professional videos,
and had a team making
those videos, and didn't do shit for me.
So I just started seeing
you, listened to what
you had to say, and was
like, fuck it, I just
used my phone, started
doing, just started filming,
you know, and just like,
with the first video
after I saw you, just got
me like, 700,000 views.
- Jesus fucking Christ.
- [Mason] The first video,
like four days after
I saw you.
For four days after, I
just made another video.
The same amount of views I
got, it changed my whole ...
- On what platform?
- [Mason] On Facebook.
- Go figure.
- On Facebook.
- [Mason] So it changed like,
my everything, and I'm just
listening to you every day.
I don't know what to, sorry,
I never, I'm a speaker,
I don't know.
(audience chuckles)
Yeah, so what I'm trying
to say is, first of all,
I know you like, your
story with immigrants,
I'm a refugee, I came
to Denmark, so I know
the hustle, I came with
nothing, I think Denmark
is the greatest country of all time,
it's just like the
opportunity we have here
is just like amazing.
I'm living the American dream in Denmark.
(audience applauds and cheers)
So, when I started doing
those videos on Facebook,
it just changed everything,
then it just started
giving me opportunities,
and I've just started
to realize that actually,
I'm doing a living,
I'm living just by
branding, personal branding,
on Danish and social media.
And just gave me jobs after
jobs after, I don't even know
what my title is.
People ask me what I do,
I don't actually know
what to say because I'm
just, I'm living my dream,
I don't know why, just
because I have this attention
on Facebook, just give me so many options,
so many opportunities.
I'm crippled by opportunities,
just like you say.
You know?
So, that's amazing, so thank you for that,
I know you live like
you're running a marathon,
and it's your legacy, and I respect that,
I love you for that.
So first of all, thank you for that.
Thank you.
(chuckles)
(audience applauds)
The second thing is just
like, just to let you know
how much of an impact you have on me,
because like, when everything
starts to get crazy,
like, I have this year,
like one year after
I started doing those
video, I have some stage
called (foreign language) here in Denmark,
it's just like a huge stage.
I have it, like, in
this month, it's almost
sold out, 600 seats, just
because I'm using your tactics
on Facebook, it's crazy.
Thank you for that.
(audience applauds)
So, the number two thing
I wanna thank you for
is just like, because,
just to let you know
how much of an impact you are ...
I have like, this dream,
I wanna buy this car,
Mercedes, yeah, it's my
dream car, I test drove it,
because now fortunately, I can afford it.
I test drove it for half an
hour, and all I was hearing
in those half an hour was your voice,
what the fuck are you doing, asshole?
(laughter)
So I was just like, I
couldn't do it, so I was still
driving around a shitty ass
car, because I'm pursuing
my dream.
- My man.
When you have that mindset,
you become more likely
to buy Mercedes the company
than that bullshit car.
(audience laughs and applauds)
- [Mason] Thank you.
So my question is, now I look just like,
I'm still new, I'm still a
baby in this like, I'm still
so new, but I speak
English and I speak Arabic.
- Love it.
- [Mason] So I started like ...
- You have a huge upside.
- [Mason] Yes.
And I realized that, so I
made a video on Facebook
in Arabic, and it got
40,000 views, I was like,
holy shit, what's happening?
And I love Denmark, but we
are only five million here.
And I know, if I put the
energy that I'm doing right now
in Danish, because
that's not a big market,
and I have this dream of
being the, you know ...
- So let me tell you something real quick.
Unless you've seen this,
this is something I'm about
to double down on.
I speak English, I fully
understand Russian,
but I'm out of practice, so
speaking it, so I'm basically
one language, I understand two.
But we're transcribing all my
videos into every language.
So you could do them, in
three different languages,
but be smart.
With the technology that we have now,
and as you keep building up
fame, if you make a video
right now saying, I'm looking
for interns to translate
my content from English
to all languages, like,
whether it's English or Mandarin or Arabic
or whatever you decide to
be the pillar to your point,
Danish is smaller, you're
better off translating it
into Danish, in written
word, but the answer
to your question is,
don't overthink this one.
I was like, just pick one.
I'm gonna save you time.
No more wasting time on
things that don't matter.
99% of things don't matter.
Technology is here.
You will be able to translate
every one of your videos
into any language you want, and over index
in Portuguese in Brazil,
and Mandarin in China,
so don't over-debate
which language you want,
I would keep, if I were
you, I would be making
all three, in Arabic, Danish, and English,
just to keep testing,
seeing, see what happens,
you learn.
Right?
Don't worry about 40,000
views versus 150,000 views,
'cause you're learning, it's
not about that one thing,
it's about buying Mercedes,
not driving the Mercedes,
got it?
So, that's what I would do.
- [Irvin] Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
I wish for all of you,
the feeling that that kind
of exchange feels like.
I wish for all of you that.
- [Woman] Alright.
Now, Kevin.
Yeah, can we get a mic runner over here?
Over here.
You can do some stretching
while you wait, Gary.
- I don't stretch.
Just kidding, I'm kidding.
- [Woman] (laughing) Meditating.
- Exactly.
- Hey.
- Hello, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Kevin] I'm fine, you?
- Amazing.
- [Kevin] Perfect.
Like, if we go back some
years, cookie-based tracking
were like, really the shit.
- What was?
- [Kevin] Cookie-based
tracking, online marketing.
But now, we are more into
the people-based tracking.
And I think it's more important, and
you can do more with it.
What do you think about
the whole Google and
only google-based tracking,
versus people-based tracking
from Facebook and Instagram and so on?
- You mean, intent based
word versus what we're doing
behaviorally?
- [Kevin] Yes.
- I think they both matter.
- [Kevin] You think they both matter?
- Sure.
I think if somebody, so let
me tell you another tactic
that maybe somebody wants to try.
As you can tell, when you do the tactics,
good things happen.
There's an ad product on Youtube, which
allows you to run a pre-roll video, based
on what people search on Google.
So, I can run ads on people who search
motivational speakers, but
even though they're watching
a skiing video, I can
put my pre-roll video
on them, because I understand
the intent-based data.
The creative has to be great.
My first three seconds on
the pre-roll has to be great,
'cause none of us want it.
But intent-based marketing
is very powerful,
and extremely good for sales.
Facebook is much better
for branding, high-impact,
he's not, he's making
videos, he's not getting jobs
because he says, and click
this and then on the landing
page and then, he's getting
it because he's building
a brand, and then they're
coming to him, the halo effect.
That's much better.
But marketing and sales both
matter, and if you're good
at both, you've really got
the game, and so I just
think both matter quite a bit.
- [Kevin] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
- [Woman] Now for a really personal one.
Bertil!
Where's Bertil?
Bingo!
Can we get a mic runner to Bertil?
- That's you right
there, right next to you.
- [Woman] Yep.
Super.
- [Bertil] Hello, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Bertil] I'm good.
And my question is, how
do you deal with people
who don't ...
Like, believe in you or
understand and especially when
those people are your
friends and your family?
- I look, I like it.
I like it a lot, actually,
to be honest with you,
because, no, I really do, I prefer it.
I even think I communicate
in a certain way to make
people confused, so that more
people don't believe in me.
I like it, Bertil, like I think it's,
I think it's the most
fulfilling thing in the world,
to achieve something and
look at one of your friends
and say, told you so, asshole.
(audience laughs)
Like, you know, look, I said it earlier,
this is a tough question
for me, and let me tell you
why.
Through DNA, through
circumstance, through parenting,
I actually am not kidding, I prefer it.
Other of my dearest friends,
my sister, for example,
she does not prefer it.
You know, but what I can
tell you is, at the end
of the day, when you're
94, actually, I got a,
can I recommend something?
Go spend one day volunteering
at a retirement home.
If you want to fix this,
I've got a way for you
to fix it, potentially,
and do something very nice
to the world.
You, as a young man, go
Google retirement homes.
I don't know if that's,
is that a culture here?
Okay, good.
'Cause every culture's got, go and email
every retirement home
near you, and ask them
if you're allowed to volunteer for a day.
Then, go and volunteer.
When you're volunteering,
make sure you do whatever
they tell you you need
to do, but every minute
you have, talk.
'Cause they want to talk to you anyway.
What you are gonna learn is a lot.
And the biggest thing
you're gonna learn is,
all those friends and
family's opinions, at the end
of the day, aren't gonna matter.
And you're gonna have a lot of regret, and
the scariest thing when
you look an old person
in the eye, when they know
there is no more ten years,
it's always about regret.
It's always much more
about what they didn't do,
than what they did.
And I don't want that for
you, and I think the one thing
that may set you straight
is a nice full day
at a retirement home.
- [Bertil] Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- All of you should do that.
It's a really interesting thing.
I'm about to do an
episode with the D Rock,
because I've been talking a lot about it.
Perspective.
You know.
Regret.
I live my whole life,
everything, you wanna capsulize
everything, a lot of this is about regret.
It's the one that you
can't fix at the end.
And so many of you right
now are living your lives
based on what your parents
want you to be doing.
And you're gonna, you're
going to resent them.
You're creating the culture
of a bad relationship
with them, not a good
one, you're just putting
a bandaid on it.
(makes fart noise with mouth)
- [Woman] I'm letting it go to the masses.
So, do we have hands, yeah?
Do you wanna pick one yourself this time?
- Yeah, that kid in the corner, actually,
ironically in the same
area, I noticed him earlier,
so let's start with him.
- [Woman] Perfect.
- Hey, brother.
- [Man In Audience] Hi Gary,
I want to ask about what's
your opinion on block chain?
- I think block chain is the
technology right now that has
the most potential to disrupt society.
I think people are grossly
underestimating what
it means, what it's doing.
Block chain is creating
infrastructure around trust,
and trust between all
of us with each other
with nobody in between, not central banks.
Not leasing companies.
Not even governments.
I think that it has the
potential to create the
global next war, 'cause it's so big.
- [Man In Audience] Thank you.
- You're welcome, what do you think?
- [Man In Audience] My personal ...
- Yeah, go ahead.
- [Man In Audience] My personal opinion,
I really like it ...
I'm really bad at listening
to myself when I talk,
- No worries, go ahead.
- So I stop accidentally.
- [Man In Audience]
But I like it a lot ...
- Why?
- [Man In Audience] I mean, I think it's
a really interesting, new,
architecture, I guess you could say,
'cause it's almost 100% ...
I mean, it's decentralized,
so there's no one controlling
it.
- That's right.
- [Man In Audience] And ...
I mean, it has a lot
of power I just think,
I don't know how to explain.
- Do you think that China
and America and Russia
are gonna let it see its power?
- [Man In Audience] I mean,
I don't think they like it,
but since it's decentralized,
I don't think there's
any way to stop it.
- Sure there is.
- [Man In Audience] Can
you give me an example?
- Sure, they can start
suppressing their citizens.
- [Man In Audience] Yeah, okay (chuckles).
I don't have a counter-answer to that.
- Okay.
I don't either, by the way.
I'm just super, I don't,
the reason I'm exchanging
right now, is I don't,
people are like, bitcoin!
Guys, get educated on what's
actually happening here.
Like, pay attention to the
conversation we just had
a minute ago.
This is a big deal.
I don't know.
I don't know either.
You got something on it?
- [Woman In Audience] What is block chain?
- Block chain is a protocol, I guess,
it's an infrastructure,
I don't know what people
are calling it, what is it, a protocol?
- [Man In Audience] It's
engineer big network,
which every piece of information is stored
in blocks, and it's publicly
viewable, so everyone
can see it and verify
that everything is true.
- And there's mining technology
that creates the people
that stamp it.
- [Man In Audience] Yeah,
that's the ecosystem.
- The ecosystem is around
miners, which are machines,
it's basically, you and I,
you will sell me your home
in 11 years, and our
transaction will happen
on the block chain.
- [Woman In Audience] Nobody else.
- Nobody else, which means all those fees
in between you and me ...
So, you know, I don't talk
about it a lot, because
as you can tell, I don't
even know every terminology,
I've been paying attention, I
bought bitcoin four years ago,
I'm watching.
But ...
Fuck, it's heady.
It's, you know, I'm laughing,
'cause everyone's like,
bitcoin!
I'm like, ugh.
Do you know what Ethereum is, do you know
what block chain is, like,
this is very intense.
What, you know, I think it's youth naivete
that says, Russia and
China, and America, can't do
anything about it.
It is literally, literally, literally,
the thing that can undermine them.
- [Man In Audience] Yeah.
- They're not that interested in that.
- [Man In Audience] Of course not.
- Yeah, cool.
- Thank you.
- Okay, you got it.
(audience applauds)
- [Woman] Speaking of
technology, the tech guys
want you to pull it a
little closer to your mouth,
can you do that?
Thank you.
Next question, do you
wanna pick one yourself?
- Yeah, how about the
dude all the way up in
the corner there, and then
I wanna go to that, we're
gonna go to that dude next.
And then I wanna pick a lady.
Got you, I see you.
- Hey.
- Hey, Gary.
- [Man In Audience] My name is Mess.
My question contains
business to business sale.
What is your biggest advice
within business to business
sale, customer relationships, or is it
chance through Facebook or
LinkedIn social or something?
- So, usually the answer is, hold the mic,
so I love that you started
with customer retention,
right?
I think everybody's hunting,
they forget about farming.
Usually, the best way to
build a real big business
is to keep the ones you got,
as much as getting new ones,
right?
- [Mess] To hunt or be hunted.
- What's that?
- That's right.
Well, to me, it's more
about hunting and farming.
Being hunted is your
competitors, at least, how I
think about it.
To me, it's farming.
You got something, you got a seed, and now
you cultivate it, right?
You don't want customers
for one year, you want them
for 11.
It's a far more interesting model.
My question to you is, what's
the biggest vulnerability
in your opinion?
The hunting or the farming, right now?
In your company?
Retention, or acquisition?
- [Mess] It's actually acquisition.
- Great.
It's probably 'cause you're
spending marketing money
in dumb places.
- [Mess] Probably, yeah.
- Good.
So don't.
(audience chuckles)
- [Mess] That's a good advice.
- Thank you (chuckles).
But like, you know, I think
it's Facebook and LinkedIn,
I think it's influencers,
I think it's long form
content, I think it's starting a podcast
for the industry, I
think it's white papers,
I think it's videos, short
and long form on Facebook,
I think all that stuff works.
And as you know, when you look
under the hood, most B to B
companies are spending
5% of their money on
all the things I just
said, and 95 on Google,
spamming on LinkedIn, B to
B magazines, direct mail,
trade shows, sponsoring dumb shit.
- [Mess] Actually, was
a good advice, earlier,
about the targeting
the co-workers and the,
in the companies that you want to target.
- And then make creative,
'cause I want to make sure
everybody's listening, it's
not just the targeting,
you gotta make the video, say, does
your head of finance
understand, or, you know,
you gotta set that person
up, because that employee
may be a secretary, a salesman,
you know, an IT department
person, they're not gonna
just, it's not for them.
So the way to make it
for them is asking them
does your CEO know, to,
you know, you're looking
for somebody who cares about
the business and's like,
oh, shit, you know?
So be smart, but content
is the variable of success.
I got in front of you here today.
Now the talk was gonna
be the variable of what
happens with us going forward.
The content is the variable of success.
He looked at, you know, I
smiled, I almost stopped him,
but he was on a roll,
he said I owe it to you,
your tactics, his execution.
He heard me, he understood Facebook video.
Facebook video has more
upside than Youtube,
it's easier to break out.
The end.
Like, he understood, he watched
carefully, I got to him,
but it was his charisma, and
capability to story tell,
that has made him successful.
There's plenty of people
that have listened to me.
And made a video, and
nobody fucking watched it.
Cool.
- [Mess] Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Man In Audience] Hello, is it on?
- Yep.
- [Man In Audience] So, thank you so much
for your time, and I'm a
guy who's, I like systems
and practical stuff.
- I'm sorry?
- [Man In Audience] I'm a
big fan of practical things,
and so recipes in terms
of how to do things.
- Okay.
- [Man In Audience] And
what I want to know is,
what would you do to grow
an influencer organically
on social media, Facebook,
Youtube, these platforms?
- Organically?
- [Man In Audience] Yeah.
- On Instagram, I would use 15 hashtags
as the first comment after
the post, after I spent
40 to 60 hours
understanding which hashtags
were the perfect balance
between a lot of people
use them, but they're
not one of the top 25,
because I'll never
penetrate it, because I'm
too small.
Got it?
Number two, I would DM as many influencers
in the same 50 mile radius,
or interests, if the person
can travel, as me, and I
would DM them to figure out
what I could do for them, in
return for them collaborating
with me, and taking a
picture on their account
and tagging me to siphon
their audience to me.
- [Man In Audience] Yeah, perfect, got it.
What about Facebook and Youtube?
- Youtube I'm gonna punt,
because the organic nature
of Youtube is so
predicated on the creative
and collaborating is far more intense than
taking a photo, so I'm just gonna punt it.
Facebook I would email
people that have media pages
around, what does the
influencer do, what genre?
- [Man In Audience] So, entrepreneurship.
- Entrepreneurship.
I would go to every
entrepreneur media site
on Facebook and email them and ask them
if they wanted any of the
content that this person
was producing for free,
to post on their page.
- [Man In Audience] Okay, perfect.
- Now, everything I
just told you, on the DM
and the emailing, you're
gonna get one out of
every 50 people responding, so you need
to hit 37,000.
- [Man In Audience]
Perfect, okay (chuckling).
I got one last thing, punt it?
- It's an American term, when in football,
when you play, if you
don't get a first down,
you punt to the other
team and they start over.
I'm just saying, take Youtube and fuck it,
win on Instagram and
Facebook first, and then
leverage that to build on Youtube.
The stakes are, it's just too hard,
supply and demand and tactics
on Youtube, to break through,
there's a lot of titles and thumbnails,
even I haven't really fully penetrated.
There are people that are better at it.
I don't like to give advice
when I don't know everything,
and so, and I also know
the other two right now
are underpriced.
- [Man In Audience] Perfect, thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
My friends, I know a lot
of you don't know me,
and we've been hanging for a little while,
that was a very tactical question.
Others have been so fucking philosophical.
I just need people to
understand, we'll go right to
this lady over here.
The philosophical strategy
stuff is way more important.
Like, a lot of you like
that last question,
like a lot of you liked it.
I know your personalities.
But I'm telling you, that's the commodity.
There's 8,000 answers to that question.
On Google, if you search
how to grow organically
on Instagram.
Finding somebody that
communicates to you, that
breaks through your mindset
and creates a new strategy,
that's the ROI.
And I may be that person
today and I may not,
but continue to seek somebody
to get you in the right place.
If you can't get there yourself.
Hi.
- [Fabiola] Hi, Gary.
My name is Fabiola, and ...
There is a lot of men fans
of you, and there is also
a lot of women, and I'm one of them.
- Thank you.
- [Fabiola] And ...
Maybe people look at you, and think
Gary V, he's so confident,
and, but what about me,
I'm not that confident.
- Right.
- [Fabiola] So, what is your
biggest secret, to become ...
- More confident?
- [Fabiola] Yeah, be more
fearless and take chances
to step up where maybe people are hiding.
- Yep.
So, you know how earlier,
I said I don't know how
to teach you empathy?
'Cause I don't.
I used to answer this
question the same way.
And then the cool thing
about life is, you get
wiser, you watch and
something breaks through,
and I actually have an answer for this,
and I don't say it a
lot, and I'm super pumped
you asked me, so thank you.
You need to do two things.
You need to start hanging out with people
that are overly confident.
You need to look around your world.
Friends of friends, go to
meetups, look in your office.
Remember a friend from
college or high school.
You need to become
friends with more people
that are confident, and
tomorrow, you have to cut out
one of your friends who's
pessimistic and negative,
out of your life.
Not totally.
But you don't need to talk to her or him
three times a day, maybe
three times a month.
This is an energy game.
- [Fabiola] So, are there something that,
when you are thinking
about it, you are still
afraid of?
- I'm afraid of snakes.
(audience chuckles)
I'm not afraid of anything
emotionally, other than
death, even that, I'm
starting to finally get there,
in the last two or three years.
Nothing emotional.
Nothing emotional, I'm afraid
of the health of my family.
- [Fabiola] The health of your family.
- That's it, the only thing
I ever, like, eh, you know,
is thinking that my
kids and wife are flying
to Florida the other
day, what if that plane,
like, that's tough.
But only that extreme.
Not, I don't think anybody
can do anything to me.
Which puts me way ahead of everybody.
I do not believe that anybody
can do anything to me,
and that is more about
me taking responsibility,
more than anything else.
Once you eliminate that,
once you don't think
anybody else has any effect on you,
once I have, I have something
else, which is the cousin
to that, that makes me strong.
I don't expect anything from anybody,
and I've never done
anything ever in my life,
with an expectation of
something in return.
That's ahead of 99% of people.
- [Fabiola] But when
you started, there must
be something you were scared
of, where you just was,
oh my God, I cannot handle this.
- No.
- [Fabiola] No?
- The only thing that was
different, when I started
professionally, then
everything I just told you,
is I was fearful that
people would feel that
my dad handed it to me,
and I would never get
the credit I deserved,
but that was a 17 year old
mindset that evolved pretty quickly.
I took care of that in the first 24 months
by growing the business
from three to $20 million
like that.
- [Fabiola] Okay.
Yeah, so ..
- Thank you so much, Gary!
- You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
- Listen.
For all of you.
Two new friends that are
confident and positive
cut out one person that's
negative, including
if that's your sister.
I'm being fucking serious.
- [Fabiola] Already did.
- Good.
(audience chuckles)
I mean it.
It's not like you cut them
out, you never talk to them,
but you have to reframe the conversation,
because negative energy,
misery loves company,
is the currency that
nobody is talking about.
That's how you get more confident.
You're around people who want you to win,
and they make you ...
I'm doing it for you!
For my hardest core fans,
I'm the one doing it
for you!
I'm so confident that you, you know why
I've made more people do things?
Because we create such
a intimate relationship
in the way that I'm producing content and
interacting with you, that there's almost
a weird friendship, even
though I don't know you yet,
so that if you fail, you
feel like you could be like,
Gary, you could like blame me!
And I love it.
I'll take every blame.
- [Fabiola] Okay, I just have
the last question, because
how are you actually
communicate to influence like
you, as, I really want
you, I can be honest,
you say I should be honest?
I really want you on my
podcast, Fabiola Share,
because I want the greatest
leaders and the biggest
visionary people ...
- I'll do your podcast.
- [Fabiola] Okay!
That's a deal.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Fabiola] That was all I needed.
- Email me at gary@vaynermedia,
say I was the woman
that waited to the bitter end to ask to be
on the podcast, I will get Tyler involved,
tschmidt@vaynermedia,
you can watch the videos
of this if you forget,
but I'm gary@vaynermedia,
and I'll do your podcast,
and then you'll go
to every other leader, and
because I did your show,
they'll do it too, and because you asked,
something good will happen.
- [Fabiola] I fucking love you, thank you,
thank you, thank you!
(audience cheers and applauds)
(screams with enthusiasm)
- Let's give it to her.
To this lady.
- [Woman In Audience] Hi, Gary!
- How are you?
- [Woman In Audience]
I'm your favorite fan,
you know why?
- Why?
- [Woman In Audience] No,
actually, favorite public.
It's because I don't know you!
And the only reason I'm here today
is actually very funny,
because you probably DM
Tony Robins, and I saw you
on a video with Tony Robins
and I'm a Tony Robins girl,
and that's why I'm here ...
- I didn't DM Tony Robins,
seven years ago, Tony
Robins emailed me and asked
me to speak at his conference,
because I create content,
so people ask me, instead
of the other way around.
- [Woman In Audience] Then
I should ask Tony how ...
But congratulations.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- So I did that episode
with Tony, and that's how
you first became aware
and that's how it started.
- [Woman In Audience] Yes, exactly.
- Okay, go ahead.
- And because the name of
- [Woman In Audience] My
company doesn't matter, but
it has something with elevating people,
and the reason I'm here
and I've been sucking out
everything you said, because
I've been writing every word
that comes out of your
mouth, because I believe
we learn from people with experience,
I talked about it with Casper.
A lot of people think
that knowledge is power,
and I think that application
of knowledge is power,
and learning from somebody
who takes all that knowledge
and puts it into, applies into his world,
I can learn something from you.
- I agree with you.
- So, I started
- [Woman In Audience]
My company two days ago,
it doesn't matter what I sell, what I do.
But I'm in a place where everybody here
would love to be, because,
I have a market, and
I want to be very smart with
how I come out with my product.
I have been giving value
to people for the last
three and a half years without asking
for anything, so I have a market ...
- How?
- [Woman In Audience] By
showing up, giving talks,
doing voluntary work for ...
- Go ahead.
- [Woman In Audience]
Non-profitable organizations,
and 1.2 million people
know who I am today,
and they basically say, what is it you do,
what is it you sell we can buy?
- How do you quantify that number?
- [Woman In Audience]
Rotary International.
- What's that?
- [Woman In Audience]
Rotary International?
- I don't know what that is, but go ahead.
- [Woman In Audience] Well,
Rotary is a non-profitable
organization doing good
in the world, and I
promote fundraising for
doing good in the world.
Doesn't matter.
I have a product at the
moment, which is a service,
and I am standing in a
place where two days ago
I started my company, and
I haven't really come out
with the product, because I wanna ask
the very crucial question.
Fast first, or second safe?
Should I let somebody
else go out with my idea
and try it, and learn
from all the mistakes,
or should I be the first one, now, I'm an
entrepreneur in my core, because
I started two organizations
and I know I'm good at
it, and I put 18 hours
a day and I don't see my children.
I know I can do it.
But now it's money, until now,
I've been doing it for fun,
I've been doing it voluntarily,
but now it's like, putting
my own money out there.
Should I let somebody
else do it first and then
learn from all the mistakes?
Or should I just go head first and learn
from my own mistakes, but
then, somebody else will learn
from my mistakes, and go faster?
- Why can't you learn
from your mistakes first
and go faster too?
- [Woman In Audience]
Well, because until now,
I wasn't attached, I
started two organizations.
- No no no, real quick, not
the personal mental question.
You said that you're gonna
go, you know, you painted
a picture, and you said,
and what I'm worried about
or debating.
Is if I go first, somebody's
gonna see the mistakes
I make, they'll go second
faster, and I understand.
You know, everybody,
early bird gets the worm,
the second mouse gets the cheese, right?
I understand the theory.
It's very basic.
- [Woman In Audience] Because
my market is there ...
- Let me tell you something
you need to reconcile.
No purebred entrepreneur ever
thought about going second.
So you have to wrap your head around that.
(audience applauds)
When it wasn't money, you
were deploying entrepreneurial
tendencies, you weren't
being an entrepreneur.
So, you've gotta wrap
your head around that.
The fact that you're even debating it ...
- [Woman In Audience] Actually
I'm not, it's something
that came up since I met you.
Because you have applied
all those things that
you're teaching us on your
own business, and you got
better, and you're very
good at saying, okay,
17 years ago, I wasn't so good at it.
I wish I could've done
it better, and today,
people are doing it better
because of your experience.
- And so you should just do it.
- [Woman In Audience] Just do it.
- Because the only thing, I can't see,
we're not spending enough
time here, unless you're
worried about the failure ...
- [Woman In Audience] I'm not.
- Or other peoples' opinions?
- [Woman In Audience] Absolutely not.
- Then you've created a fake narrative.
Amazon and Google and me
and others, we went first,
we failed, plenty other
people here, they went first,
so forget about, I'm
not, I don't want to put
myself with them, people that've won here
have gone first, failed, fixed it,
and gone faster before, you've
created a fake narrative
that somebody's gonna be second.
First of all, nobody
gives a shit about you.
- True.
- Or me.
- So nobody's really watching.
So let's start with that.
That should make it much
easier for you to go first.
Second of all, the person
that goes first and fails,
nine out of ten times,
is the one that adjusts
and goes fast again.
This second mouse?
Is not as cool as you think.
- [Woman In Audience] Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, we would love
to take more questions,
but unfortunately, you're
also moving forward,
and we have a lot scheduled
for the rest of you.
But I would like to ask
a question, regarding
the whole mass in here, because Elevate,
for several years have been a community.
A community of people
coming back every year,
I can recognize many of you sitting here,
but we have also many new people here.
So, what is your best advice
to Casper, and everybody else
about how to create an amazing community?
- An amazing community for
the organization's benefit,
I assume, which would be right ...
- No, also for each other,
many of the people here
do business together and
have learned each other ...
- So, it's super simple.
You create a framework that
allows them to communicate
with each other.
Whether that's through
email or a Facebook group
or an app that you build,
you'll decide how to do it,
but the biggest ROI for
people here, is for the people
that are the least extroverts
and won't go up to somebody
right now and say hello
and exchange who are you,
is the ability to
interact with each other.
There's, the reason I
ever go to anything is for
the follow up email, I don't
go to many conferences,
but I'll go to a lot of
dinners where I don't know
anybody else.
And it'll be 12 people
from different backgrounds.
The 99% reason is because,
once I make context,
the email that comes the next night
that puts everybody on the
same thread, I can pick
the three people that I
wanna email out of that
and say hey, let's follow
up on that, or let's
do business together, or I
can help you, or I've got
an employee that's ready
to move on, who's great,
she wants to be an entrepreneurial person,
not an agency, you should hire her.
The great thing that you
could do for everybody here
in this community is build
a framework that allows them
and pushes them, and helps
them, and coddles them.
That woman almost didn't
ask, if we didn't hold on
100th of a second longer,
she almost didn't ask for
the thing she wanted to
ask, and since she did,
it's going to change at
some level, her business
and her life.
She, we all were just here.
She was this close to not asking.
She didn't ask!
Luckily, we putzed around
for a couple more seconds,
and she fucking finally got
the, and she went there,
right?
There's a lot of people here who are
literally right now
sitting next to a person
that can change the course
of their lives and career,
and they're not gonna say
anything to each other,
because that's not the way they interact.
In life.
And if you could do
anything that gets them
to do that, then you're
doing them a great service.
(audience applauds)
Listen, we've talked about
two cents, four cents,
six cents, let's go, we gotta go.
No, no, let me close it.
You kind of missed, you missed the, yeah.
Vlog, but we love him.
A little bit more than D
Rock, slightly behind, what,
anyway, nonetheless, would love to get
your thoughts, would love
to get your two cents
on this keynote.
We'd love to get your
favorite quote, because
the team is starting to
suck and these Instagram
quotes, so now I need my community.
What was your favorite quote?
Actually, that's it, fuck your two cents.
What was your favorite
quote from this keynote?
(piano music)